sto sempre facendo check che funzioni al
ai ragazzini volta che parto però anche
per questa roba rimane come video quindi
giustamente i primi secondi di chi apre
il video dice ma chissà come era pronto
per partire il live si si nessuno era
pronto neanche chi siete piacere ciao
raga il buon pomeriggio a tutti ci sta
anche la neo buongiorno ragazzi ciao
raga c'è ora che so bene gli show belli
lo vediamo che la rai non e pubblicano
la serata si è sempre sempre sempre
visivo allora raga purtroppo purtroppo
purtroppo non è ancora stato fissato il
problema della chat ti aspetta oggi è
stato fissato me lo dicevi ragazzi
funziona la chat madonna rega purtroppo
con nova dai ragazzi va bè ragazzi
funziona anche la chat pubblica quindi
adesso posso verificare le cose o
incredibile incredibile o fare che
modifica di ho fatto salve le è rimasto
spesso segnato per mano
infatti se c'è qualcosa che non funziona
ha oggi battuto el gato è strano
ciao ragazzi buongiorno allora allora
premessa intervento quello che è oggi
oggi oggi non faccio tornei robe di
rocket per un motivo perché non sappiamo
che cosa faremo perché allora dovevamo
iniziare alle tre e mezza poi
slittato di mezz'oretta per è perché ha
avuto in un casinò
l'altro computer sta implodendo raga
ragazzi che è successo
ragazzi ma cosa si sia avviato avviato
avviato rocket league e l'altro computer
non quello dove ho attivato loro che è
successo l'altro l'altro c'è l'altro è
come se io accendo la macchina e la tua
macchina si spegne non so capendo però
va per tutte le rose
stavo dicendo prima che quasi in casi
nasse tutto aspetta che tutte le cose
che diciamo le cose eccovi allora stavo
dicendo poi visione storici ma mi sa ke
bella schermata con vista visto il
colore di strani e ha solo nome questa
cosa che comunque grazie giulio siccome
non sapremo cosa faremo oggi perché
allora il discorso è che sono scusati ho
invitato quando tu mi ha invitato il
giusto giustissimo vale mastino siccome
oggi dovremmo fare si opti con stef
pietro addirittura perché nichi non asi
of thieves non siamo riusciti a vedere
nemmeno leo non è computer signoris
monassi of tv sul perché sono i
manutenzione quindi adesso vediamo
questo andremo a fare perché per niente
io da oggi dovevamo fare
sì ortisi con io step
nichi è un amico di step perché leo non
è computer poi mi chi non la si ortiz e
quindi è subentrato pietro perotti ortiz
è in manutenzione
proprio oggi che dovevo andare in là e
strambi del subentrato rock e quindi è
subentrato rocket liga vediamo quanto lo
faremo ragazzi perchè dipende se so che
tu lei riesce a darmi in feedback sia
appena giorno dice leo è il nostro alert
di quando si ortiz torna perché adesso
sta dando parecchio volevo portarlo
anche per questo visto che ti sta
piacendo parecchio veniamo riportando un
po però se si dovesse tornare online
leoci l'ottimo seguiti che era subito
cielo si vedono poche parole diego
bianchi freddo ratio nel frattempo
aspettiamo che arrivino stef en france
che dovrebbero arrivare
penso a momenti dovrebbero arrivare tra
una decina di minuti
speriamo tanto in tutto sto casino io
non ho non ho sirtis della giornata sono
scaricato però va bene sono scarico
fisco stabilità mentis che tanto meno
dimenticare le nuvole i problemi perché
scaricando cito rimettere centri gente
ci mette poco no rega ma ci mette un
sacco di meno allora dovrebbe fare
abbastanza palo l'incrocio oggi
cominciamo alex coprono il comité già
come ti dedico questo non gol dai dati
ho sbagliato sbagliato però attenzione
che è quello si è cagato sotto
baila gay potrebbe essere gol palo gol
da al colle perché proprio noi in
sapendo già che avrei preso il palo
infatti erogato famoso proprio
tra le pa papam
mamma mia relazione ragazzi vediamo
vediamo un po come si voleva la
situazione ha detto leo che ha giocato
un sacco di ortiz che sicuramente è
sicuramente che in di base
quando mettono un pò che promettono un
pochetto quindi vediamo un po filippo e
giacomo caro grazie mille della boe
nazione si dice donazione da noi ragazzi
nell'abbonamento ok vince chi vince
ok tanto non si è visto la mia nuova
macchina e ho sbagliato non si fa
scavalcare alemanno vista non ripartono
riparto da riporto fanno buono so sto
dipartono che spingono hero è per questo
che persino tv qua non sto facendo
non stiamo facendo un torneo classico
con gli scritti oggi ragazzi perché non
sappiamo quanto dura star o potrebbe
anche dura 4 ore store o che come cinque
minuti dipende quando tornano i server
online di si opti graffio penso io ero
convinto che l'anas che fossero andati
non c'era nessuno bravo l'idea post
[Risate]
office come dai fa niente
ero in difficoltà sempre da un
avversario persone festanti sbagliato un
po di massa che ripara vani in crediamo
roma da fa in porta nostra nasce con una
parata non bella così si sta un po
cappottando da solo pensione che fa
contro la scia world di prova a mettere
in chat a con l'avversario siluro è
partito alessio qualche minto e giacomo
giacono andare a cambiare chiamarlo
giacono giacono no
giacomo annamaria anche dei caravan
e la di decide non è sommesso anche in
mezzo per che detto così gino quintegia
cosa no dicevo che parte anche bene sta
partendo bene la partita
se queste riscaldamento ragazzina è
rimasta del anche no no no no no
parliamo dove perdiamo usa mi preoccupa
ho provato a fare detailing un po a
minchia te lo giuro non ho capito la
fisica che ha gestito questo tiro
mamamia tutti gli sci in ranking
dell'innse aloso a di pro la metterei ci
ha provato a tirare proprio attenzione
che muore per la aspettava minchiam ha
scavalcato pure e allora niente
palla a lato e ha sbagliato quello che
era tira tira tira fissa non tira tira
adesso in mamma mia
taio liberato
quando ho rischiato la j
no no va bene lasciare che la ri
partenza non troppo dirti quando pensava
che la anche l'avrei controllata ma non
lo compra la formula continuare a tac e
lui le cacchio di e poi perché pensa io
volevo metterla sul tettuccio ci sono
passato sotto nettamente alessandro
grazian automation quindi non è detto
che poi sia utile se lo mettono on
lo faccio subito lo facciamo subito
chiaro e dipende da loro se le tengono
con di server perché quando dobbiamo
fare noi bahnhof line infatti caso
strano sempre ma dobbiamo giocare sempre
quando dobbiamo giocare nuovissimo e non
sono partito ho visto sto facendo dei
confini in carica che ha demolito questo
non sono riuscito a rubarti il turbo
veramente sbatti mamma mia quanti
chilometri orari 8126 perché è
rimbalzata sei volte tac tac tac e tacco
un casino disastro infinito
è quindi ragazzi mettiamo sotto appena
fuori online perché anche stef sera
connesso per fare quello purtroppo fanno
queste manutenzioni un po straordinarie
che poi era gli undici che poi erano
undici che sono state le 14 possiamo
quindi che questa cosa mi fa un po più
preoccupata wanda che giustamente la
mannara l'aipri facciamole la mattina ha
sì sì sì sì ne ho bisogno che non era l
11 a the brave facciamo balzato a detta
ma non so che il live dopo è anche
esatto acquistava al mattino pomeriggio
oggi pomeriggio sono state spostate lega
stamattina siamo liberi break
ok è stato penso che sia questo il
ragionamento dei vertici si è messa in
mezzo come lo guarda che gol che ho
fatto non ho mangiato io li ciao caro
tutto bene te come stai
ti dedico questo gol che non nostro ma
invece che questi hanno iniziato a
giocare a stamattina
questo motivo si può vedere loro perché
c'è un passe nuovo cura hanno messo
allora aspetta a partire o kay che io
intanto mi riduco icona società sente
più tu audio di carico si of thieves
perché io non ce l'ho anche scaricato
rega in tutto sto casino quindi ospite
mi riduco icona pop
ecco come si scaricano giochi dal
microsoft store che è sempre un po un
casino installa sta installando download
di sirtis ok
quanto manca 55 35 e non hai fatto già
uno si sta scaricando a 500m blues
sufficiente un bebè aspettavi restivo
l'audio ragazzi perché scusatemi no sono
megabit lega no 60 61
allora lasciamo quast'anno nino allagare
sembra giusto dai perché teoricamente
dovrei dovrei la gare di meno cioè dove
magari di più ma non scaricare sono
scarico largo di meno questo volevo dire
la mia testa
grazie andrea della donation hanno
capito niente però campione chelsea
campione eccelso profano e no aver
sviluppato cosa so fare niente
meno male che sarà un campione celso
quindi debole stare fatemi le retare
emotiva pure no no meno male meno male a
sollecitare per la spetta proprio con
gol stati sta scaricando 55 giga di
gioco e riesce a pingare 27 0 24 dire
non è veramente possibile questa cosa è
la vera partita questa come avevano
tirato strano che lo attraversa
l'abbiamo presa allo stesso quello ha
tolto tutti gli ho tentato un tiro di
reni non sono riuscito il colpo di reni
che fa western hai visto cosa forbice
che c'è una un campione eccesso stagione
10 gente carriera grand champion ne so
ma ne sa di più la ti aspetta mattina ok
no che l'ho presa quando era la sua
terra porca vacca vela prendeva lo
stesso felice
giacomo ne ho visto adesso che la palla
storia ma il controllino dell'agenzia
non era sembrata non sarebbe una partita
delle pietre la rete certo un bel tiro
bel gol
mi dispiace abbandonati perché si sta
impegnando spacca di tutti i pro non ti
preoccupare
almeno quando siamo in un punteggio
buono per mila euro giovanni mora
morabito morabito non so perché non so
come si pronunci ma grazie della
donation e caro age madonnaro manca
niente di vedere di tanto chi sia
giustamente è rimasto fermo alla fermata
la macchina che ho comprato ieri
cosa fa è pazzo non avevano già venduta
quella del sis infatti questa è la prima
questa tensione paralizzato prevenzione
è un pokémon tucker bellissima e per che
cosa hanno usato la paralisi
una mossa di poche ma occhio
faccio il mio compagno mamma mia che
rischio qualora che stanno segnando di
coda no sono veramente un palazzo joseph
che fare donation caro la stiamo
veramente pressando ai ragazzi cè un
campione certo io veramente non smette
di giocare fatto una roba scena
eccolo lì sono fatto scattare perdonami
fratello devi perdonarmi se abbiamo
preso questo gol è colpa mia non
l'abbiamo preso però perché lui ha
recuperato bene
mamma mia cosa non entrato li bravo zio
tieniti con bravo va bene ottima
spazzata poi i miei complimenti lo
sentite questo trapano infernale
c'entravano no è un trapano penso al mio
vicino di casa sia mettendo tutti i
quadri tutti forse ripulire mangiati di
valderice a farle ha comprati tutti a te
le marche eccolo dunque non si sente
nulla letto male perché mamma mia
ragazza e parata vice ivano turbo va a
bravo tentato di pagamento in rotazione
il tiro del mamma mia che compagno forte
hanno le statali la anno le stato di la
nice
sul 2 a 0 ma è uno rimasto non abbiamo
giocato male poi in compiti di vania
arrivo infine eccelso che se n'è andato
tutto
eccoci campione è letto che tiro
schifoso fratello bè capisco tiro
dell'avversario che entra subito in
porta sono entrati se c'era dribbling
occhio questo segna ma dai frati come
fate presto ma non ha preso
mamma mia che tocchi bravo grazie
gerardo novi ha fregato bravo manca un
minuto siamo sapremo anche un minuto
chiama jester un bot
allora
frate della bei gol
dai basta tanto te la cavi anche col bot
via sono uscito da solo è sì 30 vinciamo
45 secondi mancavano avanti con l'a.d
eccoci qua e frank ed hai visto carico
joe carico scarico stata pagata speciale
di sui rockets sempre sempre sempre
quale prima nessuno dico nessuno gioca
ben potrebbero fare una modalità a noi
saremo noi meglio nessuno nessuno
nessuno gioca per segnato ma che sa bene
traverse e pali e pali
ovviamente va bene a quali sono
collegati no perché quando siamo contro
di noi che è ancora offline
se andiamo a perderla di ripartire
allora andiamo a vincerlo è esatto
esatto siamo contati rispetto questa
volta minuto e poi venga avvisa quando i
server ti aspetti o bella partenza recto
occhio che davanti a occhio che
ripartono aiuto quindi non tifa scavalca
io domanda sul turbo bravo
niente lui conosce tutte le traiettorie
vabbè
madonna bello ma il tiro con il bottino
però chi occhio madonna che che succede
ero carico e locali che sul tema
contrasto vinto no blind tiro blind ci
ho provato
simone kwaku perché mi da giacomo caro
parco attenzione e mezzo volo ma non
segna mai
occhio che cavalcano che si è bella per
loro brutta per noi signore bellissimi
ad ora nina la mina della cina
bye bye bye come non mai mai mai mai mai
mai mai mai mai mai mai perfetto da
tolta stato bravo miseria porca miseria
a miseria fox non sempre è il comité
giacomo no che controlla 8 pessimo
pessimo proprio tornato però ha paura no
mi sono arrivato da solo a pedali
ripartiamo
e quindi facciamo anno tra iato tra jato
queste cose dai a sono compagni mi ero
perso il compagno di camilleri e rocky
ma poca misseri obama fatto quello tutto
attenzione controllo e ri partenza non è
vero non so di controllare niente oggi
oggi sono proprio pessimo nel controllo
chiocchi occhio chiocchio questi super
hanno tantissima obbligo invece una
volta bello non fu bravo e occhio dietro
perché ti se ti viene una teca non la
può sopra e non o turista non esistono
fermi
va beh io guardavo la guarda guarda un
attimo le cose basta forse è bastato non
è bastato
antonio graziani sul carro con pam pam
pam e vabbè con me la dai a me la prendo
la teca dell'ati non era buona
by erano turbo però la prendo si sono
turbo e cioè sta avanzando proprio così
a caso bravissima una mia
[Musica]
l'ho tolta male però bravo stato un po
di parate oggi 5 alcuna di questa non la
faccio
bravo faccio io però sono andati in fumo
e scusami ma ero tranquillo ispirato no
per un aggancio controllo senza l'ultimo
bravi ma sto preparando un altro mi puoi
farle qualche parata se vuoi ma ora
agata lisciata la risata laliscia tali
di soci e campione mister v non saluto
grazie sia passato caro ti ala di ma
dove ha sbagliato tutto tutto 2 fortuna
raggirando tornato ma tira un po a caso
o attraverso la nuova l'edizione di sì
sì sì sì siamo 2b 1 attraversa vai vai
vai vai vai vai vedere niente di
partenza loro e gol
mannaggia non penso adesso magari ha
fatto il pratico di 20 minuti fa è una
lotta fin qua non c'ero
orazio mitri banca me non forse no
quella velocità mi frega sempre niente
vai vai vai vai vai vai mai letto in
chiave speranze su di lui l'ho tirata ho
paura di andare infatti potere parlare e
quando nel futuro così loro le
gestiscono bene bros e quindi aveva beh
questo che fa bene
dribbling occhio vai vai vai vai se
riesci vai vai dai bravissimi che quello
intero al tiro io non ero mica che tiro
bello bellissimo bravi possiamo
prenderla potuto solo guardarlo potevo
solo guardarla
tra loro non prendono le traverse fino a
quello nella legge quando parlo sempre
spetta a me sta talmente bene che l'ho
potuto sopra guardare
vai vai dei attraverso l che con loro
ormai è normale normale di next
ormai siamo anche secondo me siamo
abituati totalmente impaurito dal fatto
di prendere la traversa che io quando
tiro guardo quelle quindi
consapevolmente la tiro sempre sì sì sì
si può fare non è bossi ma abbandonato
non auto next ciao raga buongiorno a
tutti
dato questo ci guarda che c'è un emblema
supersonic champions è un'altra volta
sempre incredibile diamante debba
arrivare a champion trovi gente che
fatturano in un dato però è tutta gente
che sa che è scesa da champion però che
telecom era lire quindi let's go
i miti abbiamo cioè no vai tu anzi ma
perché non hai fatto live stamattina
questo sherlock si aspetta attenzione o
attenzione la di là di partenza della di
che può ancora toccare la di e la mette
a lato la di niente la 10 provavo ci ho
provato io l'ho tenuta li bene esistono
insiste questo mascara bravo bravissimo
stava facendo o la mancata tocca la
tocca la toccato cara bravissimo come
non sapeva andare sugli verso la palla è
andato su un po tutte e due o mancata
bye bye bye
rossi si va in sé il senso così
bravissimo tosto esaltato ancora ma ci
hai provato a stare qua che si riparte
un casino tu lì partirà lui
mamma mia che non è cosa fai è pazzo
pazzo pazzo pazzo pazzo proprio genio
che succede chiamatemi pazzo si pazzo
perla di pazzo per la d in mezzo c'è
qualcuno quel video ma tolta la vita
l'ha tolta sistema non posso prendere
questa palla io barack e cu lo portavo
jacopo fo e convinta e giacomo caro
proprio a caso ma porca di quella vacca
buche tiro ma niente traversa esiste
anche per loro allora esiste esiste
mamma mia e basta c'è anche la rai è
tenuta la meno male brodsky ha ottenuto
avevo fatto era era non so come in
un'entrata in realtà bel controllo dello
zio non abbastanza
vai vai
ha sbagliato sbagliato mai giocato
malissimo
mamma mia
1 umano abbiamo fatto non vedo la tromba
di controllo può fare il pallone ma era
troppo prevedibile con 2000 tengo la
maledizione l'ho fatta male è schiantato
contro il fai da te non ha rilievo mi
sento così si arriva agli occhi occhio
anche agli occhi occhi occhio chiocchio
chiocchi occhiobello
ciao mamma mia mamma mia maniera col
nostro palo niente è anche rimbalzate in
motorino la potesse toccare c'è proprio
tutto sbagliato
no tutti gli sci bella mezzo come posso
non sono non posso non posso no ma no a
metà
mamma mia questi sta rischiando delle
maniere che non ti dico però non è un
trovato niente bella dato un po una teca
con uno turbo troppo scusami broschi
senza però tralasciare anche a che ha
vinto rimpallo edizione ma guarda che
questo ma mi deve demolire ma pensate
tira biak bravissimo e mezzo
niente fregato niente 49 secondi è il
momento giusto per loro per facci un gol
o chimenti robertino bravissimo vai vai
20 gol al lager di abcd almeno perdiamo
con un oro in bello ben fatto
persa lo perdiamo colon ore con onore
chi del rank silver uno zio di un treno
va di mezzo e mezzo e mezzo in mezzo si
faceva in mezzo in mezzo in mezzo di
mezza in mezzo ai mezzi e mezzo al mese
e mezzo e mezzo per loro con loro no
tanta volta secondi per pareggiare fare
coloro che faranno ovviamente come
sempre però almeno abbiamo giocato bene
da è quello del discorso
ok occhio non ti fa scaricare pronto
vediamolo sei ok
ero andato di ragazzi occhio che tira
bello luminosi ma la persona più
positiva non mi ricordo una partita che
ha visto i competivi predirgli avanti
deve essere permette quindi è normale
non esiste una legge che ci permette di
vincere
o forse sì o forse si tira tira col bel
goal non l'ha toccata pazzo pazzo
abbiamo vinto lati credibile ma perché
ho parlato lo segnala server span span
male ma che la squadra stava a prora
ritrovamento molto raro pd vento tosti
vediamo che si era ricominciata mattina
menti pro attenzione però so non mi dire
di no dai twins ma che è che così è che
cos'è lasko teca alla guerra un attimo
guarda un attimo questo sto guardando
con jerry calà sembrano ma non è una of
time la macchina ddr sarà ok non è
questa la twins
questa la differenza cioè a caso c'è un
pezzo davanti che sembra un po più per
zaia tipo un e poi dietro a un turbo che
minchia sembra che le hanno montato
volkswagen è bellissimo è veramente
bella vediamo cosa liste pro scusami ma
è veramente bella censurato il topper
test cresta di gallo testa di ok ma devo
mettere per poter essere subito il buon
set
ciao antonio grazie a tre show tutto a
pagar total terre bello massimo noemi se
c'è il sacco raga stiamo che stiamo
attenti come spettacolo trovato nappine
rosso dove vieni pure ma si artisti
funzionano funziona questo di server fla
allora abbiamo leo che ci notifica non
appena non appena torna online quindi
veniva la miniatura il titolo su quella
già imposta che devo fà sempre quando
bisogna fare live streaming sirti il
decidendo sembra mentre il proprio gioco
era imposto titolo guarda che sarrano
broschi league
bp altro non siamo di nuovo in gruppo
insieme non si scappa in avanti vetro in
qua 6 bene ok con la cristina ma mi sa
che la torba quello da 5 non ti metti la
cresta punk e io la cresta dalla cig che
si dava mi rifiuto mi rifiuto veramente
c'è misto rifiutarlo
aspetto che arrivi un gioco purtroppo
niente aspetti perché dovevano fare
manutenzione alle 11 poi si sono accorti
che che la live è stata spostata al
pomeriggio quindi detta non facciamo ad
inizio nel pomeriggio perché se ne ho
mai fatti certo è sempre la inizia il
verdetto gioco da tre anni ovviamente
non sempre come vi dicevo considerato
che doveva essere stamattina in teoria
la la manutenzione perché noi avremmo
dovuto fare la mattina però siccome
abbia spostato al pomeriggio anche
quelli di sea of this l'hanno spostata
al pomeriggio la manutenzione sia giusto
così è giusto è giusto che anche si ange
infatti non vediamo alternative ragazzi
e giochiamo a rocket finché non non
entra online è tanto il buon leo ci
notifica male ho fatti me muto e appena
so qualcosa mi ha saputo il tuo dico va
bene ma se gli è entrato in live
io no sta avviando adesso perché quello
che meno miniatura sitter un palazzo nel
light barber
accanto a lui sam birch al ven sab da
supreme dalle supreme grazie mille anche
noi siamo salvati alto ticino si salta
sposta un po non si possa fare
ma anche noi siamo di super avere
l'abbonamento da 10 euro conta come sa
però si chiamano però è spotify non è
quindi da nella percentuali ma abbiamo
una roba del genere book cioè che il
mezzo io cos'è una competitiva
io ho fatto subito competitivo non
abbiamo fatto neanche per riscaldamento
scusami no vabbè tanto io vi chiedo già
scuse ragazzi allora nelle tre v3 per
chi non avesse mai visto le live
streaming facciamo su rocket le tribù
tre sono completamente diverso dalle due
voodoo e quindi siamo radio sono solo
diamante uno qua perché purtroppo iraq
sono completamente diversi e quindi
diamante 2 fortissimo lo steff allora io
non so quando andare non capisco è colpa
mia è colpa mia
non capisco i tempi del 3 contrari non
li ci gioco ma ai ragazzi dai vediamo
allora magari che fanno con un po strani
giocando
man mano di come mai che succedeva in
realtà ci sta perché la voti nata
malissimo ci sta ci sta
mambo pilot piergiorgio da molti lati
trova la palla
scatta uno ne scarta due ma anche il
terzo ci ho provato a far neymar vino
vino attenzione alla stalla per non
steccare nazionale che la tocca e il
controllo e la di me e della tep
ok
vabbè ggv p sarà come lo punta proprio
ora
ma è la macchina nuova macchina a e
domanda cambia qualcosa ragazzi dalla
macchina dalle 8 è normale a questa che
ho sbloccato perché è molto più bello
cioè casa poi dieci volte più bella
secondo me ma voglio capire se in game
fa schifo o no quindi ditemelo per
favore grazie bella e ceci ragazzi come
lorenzo in de giacomo brother a nessuno
ma non posso davvero mai chiesto ne
andavo guardato non c'è nessuno trova
mannaia i pip
la domanda che ho fatto nessuno m'ha
risposto grazie a casini no non cambia
cambia laico non cambia i box quando
appena domanda in live la seguente
risposta non cambia niente come fa
cambiare se l'avevamo fare una macchina
e lo stesso io non lo so però chiedo lo
stesso il game è meglio lotte cosa
cambia senti anche dalla british che è
meglio non mi fido di nessuno non mi
fido di nessuno che culo dice una roba
di monumenti secondo me non ha senso che
cambi di no sono scarse ma che io sono
bronzo in realtà fine mamma mia che tiro
filtrante che avevo fatto bruttissimo ma
a rimbalzo laghi di solaris mezza
filtrata attenzione no no no mister
non è tanto re dei gol bruttissimi vero
guarda mamma non è che questa non la
light box della open è la octane che non
ha lightbox della octane ok ok mi sembra
che non ci sia nessuna criticità eccolo
che ho letto perfetto tutto a posto va
bene
nessun to the sun dubbio ne sono ma
dov'è finita la palla con che fisica
dove può essere finita non volevo io
mamma mia come l'ho toccata malissimo
tipa parte delle corrette per essere
gentili non cambiano la soluzione
estetica hanno la stessa hitbox ragazzi
non mi fido vivi niente io non mi
fiderei sull'atleta xbox live ma è
sempre e solo a vederle sono uguali i
denti che quindi non vedo come clan
debbano aver messo una tra i boss c'è
con quale criterio è bellissima questa
ragazza guardate che fini sarà
perfettamente su quel tipo per fortuna
fuori non sta in lion laurentiis vero se
stai la lega tira da questo allora sì
fuori gol perché adesso diventare la
segna per forza
quante volte deve rimbalzare per farlo
basta non hanno la stessa i post ma
com'è possibile
lì sono uguali poi dipende come ti trovi
due esse sono uguali
io l'ho tolta perché stava tirando va
bene è la riparla parla barbara d'urso
turbo turbo turbo turbo
ho fatto una cacata dove andare molto
prima invece lo spazzata con sufficiente
a niente se non la prendiamo più bravo
le sospensioni ma infatti adesso ne
faccio montare anche sulla panda sembra
il relatore del deserto quello che usa
non è il tipo che c'era su jack 3
se qualcuno mi giocata check tra i
ragazzi più turbo così a casa la mamma
mia che volger 3 ho sentito solo da me
alema e che mi capisci così si paga che
lo riguardi ora jack due era molto bello
nel deserto del treno deserto ma papà il
tè era quello deserto e poi citare
esatto esatto ossea prendendo da tre
ragazzi che proprio no ma non è vero
chiave di queste cose come sono sono
molto più ci sono forti ma non come
quelli che abbiamo battuto prima di sono
meno solo che sanno fare molto melonaie
le rotation in tre v3 perché questo fa
tantissimo fa proprio tra branca e lo
sappiamo
e vabbè che passaggio bello ma niente
dai giochiamo domani non ho preso il
tour e mi dissocio mi dissocio
mi dissocio che ti devo dire è colpa del
rischio mamma mi hanno preso turbo
niente nulla prendi vabbè dai giocatori
vabbè dai allora la giunta perché la
mano a lato eh si crei va beh
tira tira dai dai dai dai dai con classi
seconde tensione mamma mia azione
bravissimi laga e cross è uscito da qua
bellissimo poi l'ad ha trovato
l'angolino giusto anzi cerco di
stopparla rega cerco di stopparla
stampino stop conco drillo vede la palla
la punta
niente finita beatles o no si tirano
lega mamma mia che paura che parta parte
forza mio contributo in questa partita
essenziale diretto no occhio ma ndo area
[Musica]
la prende blocco no che brutta bene bene
ma che sfiga ragazzi mammamia nichi
nikiniki antonio welcome in de giacomo
caro fortuna cominciata cioè non ce
l'abbiamo provato a vincerla
scusami star tranquilli niente lui bola
e niente doppio tocco ok
vai vai palla al piede ancora lui il
nostro ronaldinho di rocket league
prende palla ma sono scarso veramente in
una maniera incredibile non lo pinch ata
neanche per sbaglio o che sono nati in
due dai ragazzi questa vincere giocando
bene
eccolo al col signore anomala teca da
lontanissimo ancora lati consiste no può
sfornare sto turbo 4 tempo 10 secondi
con che abbiamo appurato gol titoli di
attenzione ragazzi brava quello da che
siam partiti in sé ma vai contropiede
terzino che la gente vada rifiutarla
canda l'uso dei miei scritti show
madonna con una volta bene uno armato di
torno torno
io l'ho tenuta così purtroppo che in
mezzo precisa sarà bene bene bella bravo
di novara l'altro co rischiata ok non
l'ho capito questo è bruttissima
bravissimo e va bene niente allora non
deciso che ci prendono a pallonate
proprio bravo
perché uno ha dentro la porta lega
momento il momento provo a crowe star la
nona con un cretino bruttissima dava
vincere un rimpallo ma tre minuti
supplementari ragazzi e è già detta
addio vedo veniva che quello era pazzo
capaccio era lì lì spesso il tri state
vabbè grazie a pericolosissimo che sono
tutto non ho niente
io mi trovavo lì per caso mi è arrivata
la mamma mia ragazzi ok esperimenti e
mezzo bufala che sfortuna bravo
quell'ora cross pericoloso ma dove l'ha
mandata
ma perché mai e doveva analisi fratello
110 garda
peccato hai peccato l'abbiamo giocata
strabene questo secondo me e diamond 2
divisione 1 saranno argomenti e niente
io sono tristissimo perché un passato
che ai pirati all'ora x fi cos'è se non
giochiamo al sì office con man mano
barca su gta 5
andiamo a fare niente
anche va bene tanto non fa neanche
freddo non faranno o no no ti sta bene
sto periodo insieme commenta giacomo
caro lazio sardegna
così ora palici minuti proprio semplici
semplici costare dai ma che vince
megalodon usa mistero quello velato
dalla civilmente importante guarda
questo volo
è sbagliato ha applicato una non è bello
più o meno decente burger
nel dubbio
ovviamente deve rimbalzare malissimo da
di la mette a terra la stoppa punta
immagino cosa scandalosa soriga nate non
funzionano i server di divertirsi al
momento sono offline
questa è stata colpa di tutti in realtà
no guarda guarda il mio miss vabbè ci
sta che la forte è limitata a moccia
rapina di una linea
buonissimo ma come sono troppo tenere il
controllo
ok
bravi
no meno male
ci ho provato toglierlo va bene
bella è caduto storto dai ha vinto
rimpallo sul muro volta bravo il turbo
turbo turbo turbo lag a un problema
grosso poi devo fare la pipì è un bel
problema
ovviamente in questo momento veramente
un problema non ci va bene ma ora che
l'hanno tirata in due ma che culo non
puoi fare la ii sulla scrivania pro ci
ho provato ma niente a nola creata uno
solo che riguarda 27 volte dai ragazzi
dai ragazzi che la di per una volta
positivo bisogna sfruttare questa sua è
vero non sono mai positivo poi vabbè ma
chi è missile partito
cosa faccio non lo so
maria è niente che se non si lasciano
andare in attacco è quello il problema
non mi sono una palla ma neanche a
scherzare bravo a nice
con l'anticipo bravissimo e allora va
bene bravi voi perché se blu perché 4
contro 2 questa partita ed è staccato ci
credo e non regga possono solo sognare
il rinvio sul tettuccio hanno fatto
cadere proprio e vabbè questo tiro
clamoroso niente che si tirano da
ovunque
ok non turbo bravissimo mamma mia mamma
mia di giulio grazie al national qualche
video rai di arson arrivano molto presto
caro fa ha fatto presto arrivano caro
prometto
murgo cosa tolgo io qua questo è mamma
mia il rischio ragazzi ma dai
si no ok bello della stava riprendendo
incredibile così la mamma mia meno male
che c'è stefano ragazzi non vedo la
gente dietro non vedo mai sarebbe
orribile
niente ma perché ho aspettato
mamma mia che brivido però lo stesso lo
salta e a un'altra subito dopo turbo
turbo turbo bravo bravissimo scende non
abbastanza
non ho fatto una schifezza di tocco
bravo ancora mamma mia di tiro
bravissimo come mi aspettavo neanche io
infatti sono rimasto parecchio male sia
la lindo papà papà non è vero
io ci credo sia anche io ragazzi
tantissimo purtroppo non il turbo e non
me l'aspettavo ma peccato ma dai tagli e
dai e dai supplementari di prima praga è
successo chi si è rimasta lì perfetta ma
non me l'aspettavo mai balletto si sa se
con la somma come ci riesce
bello bello no peccato era buono ma da
essere staccata dal muro intanto giusto
per dar fastidio occhio occhio bravi
bravissimo prossimo quella che questo
anche con amazon
no no no è andato in anticipo ma niente
ma grazie al freni grazie mille caro
no mi ha fatto mai e grazie anche a te
antonio scusa mi sto guardando al volo
ma sono perdiamo perché fa richiedere
lei conclude resta partito non riesca
tirate abbiamo sempre il recupero
ragazzi non hanno uno scherzo ma è il
momento lo capirò invece avevano fatto
lui come si tratta lo stesso
[Musica]
quindi che gliela faccio vedere da solo
ragazzi bravissimi vado a fare la pipì
seno muoio arrivo va bene arriva allora
no prospettati perché non vorrei che
partisse in automatico altra partita
se vuoi ritornare a melo principale
troppo tardi troppo tardi
decisamente troppo tardi comunque la mia
trasformazione in coccodrillo si è
finalmente completato incontro trovato
questa skin con la bellissima non c'è
anche il cappello per la particolare lo
devo controllare sarebbe bellissimo per
tre minuti c'è il torneo da gama che
torneo ed è troppo che giochiamo al era
anche allora vi consiglio il turbo r una
rotazione in aria l 1 il salto la cielo
su hicks sì infatti dovrei mettere quei
tasti lì solo che dovevo guardarmi un
tutorial prevedere tutti tutti tutti i
tasti perché se li cambia li voglio
cambiare tutti bene e non lo faccio mai
perché effettivamente sia avere il jump
sulla sud a hicks e il bus sul cerchio è
molto scomodo poi per volare bene fare
le varie cose quindi me ne sono reso
conto anche io che un limita quindi tu
dici che per fare la rotazione in aria
il tasto giusto
teoricamente dicono che r1 il boost e
dell 1 alla rotazione e quindi coeli
direttamente gli entrambi perché così
usi gli indici e
il pollicino tieni per il salto ho
capito attivamente ha senso perché avete
comprato mentre la rotazione il late
rapata sua r1 ma se io ho scoperto che
però le rotazioni in volo sono tre ha sì
ci sono tre tasti non è uno è già
praticamente è quella classica di
rotazione che quella che io avevo
bendato e poi ce ne sono due aggiuntive
che una verso sinistra e una verso
destra ma la fa ad una velocità
differente poi di social una volta in
aria poi qualitativamente se è lei la
rotazione a simili gravissimo sono qui
ho capito pensate e io credo che la
gente forte utilizzi tutti e tre i tasti
però non l'ho ancora capito in danno 8
dita per mano per usare tutti quei 45
anni di rock e brighi non sono sicuro
dei tasti da imbarazzarsi questa 10
gioco da un anno
no no no ho cambiato da dea ho cambiato
da pochissimo il tasso della derapata è
capovolta in aria da pochissimo giocavo
sempre con i comandi così già
predefiniti e io sono ancora predefinita
credo perché la della parola sul
quadrato e invece il le ronettes lo so l
1 quello giusto avevo cambiato forse
quella risposta che ci sono un sacco di
tasti che non usiamo pippi pippi in
quello che fa la di ppp la diga e
cacchio stai facendo dare vita a
svuotare una cisterna
insomma bella azzurri ragazzi cristiana
benvenuto in giacomo boschi grazie mille
per l'abbonamento zio bella brother ha
come il signor gioco in inglese perché
così quando guardi se things they dei
video le agenti inglesi di riesco a
capire cosa toccano altrimenti non si
capisce una mazza raga prestissimo
poi ho visto che i pro ottengono anche
tipo la visuale del controller ma non la
visuale diciamo una roba virtuale e che
fa vedere i tasti che schiacciano
allora io non so tu ma quando riguarda
non ci capisco ok quindi che se premuta
tutti insieme giovedì 10 cade premuti si
ok va bene grazie grazie che mi hai
fatto vedere fattivo
penso sia utile per un altra gente ma
non per delega a expo
avevo una tanica una cisterna story
svuotando ecco l'autopompa dei pompieri
ragazzi allora ho una divisione per
salita di monte 2 in gara perdiamo
perfetto che questo l'ho sentito
cristiamo il comité già con calma il
promesso salto i knicks e rotazione aria
ea destra reazionaria sinistra triangolo
e ma come fai ad avere lo stesso tasto
per entrambe le rotazioni
no io non ho piuttosto non ho capito a
te vojo nome voglio sapere compro anche
i petali e le rotazioni a sinistra e
quella destra sull'unico tasto l'altro
sta ferma no per logica è sì contro
bilancio bianco di titanio ok questa
giocare con il volante rocket li grave
volante e pedali non credo sia facile
sarebbe una cosa incredibile da provare
però dai come matti che già che una
commossa e tastiera e che impensati
scomodissima papà papà killian
grazie caro da donation
paga o la mimetica diamante e quindi a
priori dal team in cui sono io sono
sempre coloro diamante questo visto che
per quello non perdiamo resina esatto e
poi non ti va di chiamarti tentati
abbiamo vinto penso amico più non
ricordavo più dei ricordi con la dp
incanta finale guarda lo riguarda perché
giocare con noi capito per quello ma io
vorrei chiedere di fare la modalità dove
segni se fai palo attraversa esatto
esatto
mamma mia devono fare grandi centri e un
grande chef subito per al subito grand
champion animale crunch e sei persone
supersonic la gente aspetta un bel
controllo sisters a una modalità
sembrano tutti i file in pelle nicole
attenzione leonardo graziano nesci di
tanto caro pac
ma perché ma perché ma perché dai
arrivate arriva carico no ovviamente
vince rimpallo de palo e quindi per noi
la che ancora insiste la che forse cosa
se sta a muovere è di sicuro nella
nostra barca da salvandolo sviluppino
pro s no colletto uno dello staff
sanitario dice sto prepararti che che
tra poco lo annunciano annunciamo che
torniamo ai giovani lo mamma mia che
parata quella sì finale enti avere
cambiato un missile era bello forte che
tira ma perché i colori in italia sono
membri dello staff 10 al di sotto della
realtà
il server
ufficialmente collegato con la rete ok e
penso che all'interno ci sia qualcuno
dello staff
da notare il palo interno da non l'ha
mai infatti quello che abbiamo passato
la mano io tanto mio disco ci facciamo
anche neanche guardo ps cose tutto è
così e non nullo madonna passaggi
all'indietro
mamma mia no perché ho fatto questa cosa
brutta mi6 finita ok i centri già
devastato ci sarà presentato il gioco a
caso è bello un mai spingeva pigra
fisica vabbè dai latini 18 è un roster
di pace
sembrava il ticino quello lì no di due
turbo reagan
non potevo togliere nessun modo
mannaggia mica da messa anche bene
mannaia
non potevo proprio toglierla io ho
saltato però se avessi avuto proprio
anche solo 10 di turbo
peccato quello col colpo fermi
esattamente dove va la palese la vita ma
la mia pelle già prima mattina brano
bravo meno male nice
wow e allora mamma mia
devo toccarla meglio brino sono chiuse
le palle che ti salgono dietro tanto
mariella welcome in degiacomi abbiamo
anni e marianna niente niente niente
proprio un tocco che non più brutto non
poteva resistere pure gol
no la germania hanno preso il turbo
ottimo bravo
ok vengono tutta donna mamma mia lo
stesso non ho turbo io so fare solo
questo
faccio un grosso dei no no no non ci
credo che fortuna no madonna andavo
anche quello toccato domanda perché sono
un bronzo due ma dai ma dai ma dai
a essere il coccodrillo dai dai una miss
agazzi ma dai
mamma mia che mostra sbilanciati ma non
ci arriva in tempo cioè sono arrivato la
scorsa di grosso e rimane lì ma arriva
quello era già pronto lui sapeva già che
era lì la palla perché in realtà sto
giocando con loro sudditi è però ero
troppo sul palo
bello bello questo no però quello di
fatto così e becco lega zecca vecchia e
non ho niente so solo sognare ok però
fai sognare anche noi di quando fai così
in una mina non è vero ma figurati se
per caso un controllo decente esce fuori
che va dai la risata non ci credo io ho
usato per il turbo per non celato la 10a
no mamma mia sto toccando così io però
si cerchi un'altra ferma bene va bene
per avanti e vabbè tiro pericoloso rai
erano in tempo e ho sbagliato la rai uno
turbo rega ragazzi bravo ma era già lì
ok pid luisa bravo per fortuna ero là
grosso e cela bene bene dai
niente meravigliato non esistono ne
avevo fatto bene all'inizio poi dopo
scandalo bravo ok no mannaia mica io
torta prefermento mi vuole demolire
scusa al ragazzo che mi stava demolendo
grazie tranqui
queste panatta grazie organizzato nation
tutto a posto caro grazie mille piango
da piangere duro per convincerla insomma
va bene può succedere siamo nella
situazione in cui li li per vincerle e
le perdiamo è questa è la nostra vita è
sempre per vincere e prendiamo palo ma
oggi qui da qui dalla centrale rv posso
confermare l'allarme falso allarme qui
dal mar dei caraibi
l'inviato speciale honduras venga
aggiornati per i prossimi sviluppi
accederci insulti
grazie leonardo passiamo quindi la linea
da te che è ok mamma mia
sarei passata nel momento giusto per gl
sticks grazie caro dell'abbonamento al
giacomo e niente dai vediamo un'altra
volta
bel gol e vabbè costiero ok ok turbo
quando mi fa felice adesso prendo io se
vuoi va bene è niente ma va fatto ok
questo qua con hanno vinto il me va bene
contrasto per ok bravo perché la toscana
se non nullo questa incredibile bimbatti
traversa
traversa di nuovo c'è palo non ci credo
ha piantato anche ragazza se non la
tocco neanche arano ok easy pompati
grazie fortino questo tolto anche
l'addio tolto grazie direttamente in gol
guarda
si no ecco lo bello spaccato riuscita s
va bene niente
ecco rimane ma che vedo madonna ragazze
rischio abbiamo preso cioè non so come
sia possibile meta che entra
ho mangiato in sei e data
mammamia meno male che hanno lasciato
tokyo 8
la tep anno leone non prende un buon dai
caraibi caraibici celac sono tornato qui
purtroppo il vento forte e sistemica le
antenne quando vengono fisicamente si
fanno se ne vengono tenute con un
nastrino al al pavimento
no non posso prenderlo ma dai ma dai non
l'ho presa a nessuno l'ha presa nessuno
gioca questo giocano l'agi la parola
linkiamo ha legami voglio non lo so non
sono io che sull'effetto riguarda devo
stare veramente egitto perché posso
controllare nota scritta io ero convinto
ai riflessi in porta non era lì a tema
tecnico ero proprio convinto che fosse
in poco convinto avesse di race stefy
prova intercettarla se no col cavolo
cacchio proprio un band positioning
orino una maserati e una panda del 90 la
mamma mia se poteva bene ho segnato la
vampata hai segnato la vampata nuovo
pezzo tra la gioca e guerra come salta
tutto storto entra
ok per un attimo turbo
peccato ma ben doppio tocco che ha fatto
dai non così ma perché il loro diventerà
re così facilmente perché il palo non
esiste per gli altri ma toccherà super
lati si è data da un tocco mio perché
l'avevo messa a voi è un piccolo
arrivato però non possibile a in tributo
bella
provate a tirare la di non male dai non
mario de caro tommaso eccomi de giacomo
caro fastidio
guardate questo mi ha detto care va bene
bravo
un bel no mica non me l'aspettavo e non
me l'aspettavo
le mani non me l'aspettavo scusa se ci
avessi voluto avrei buttata dentro
tantissimo che era talmente dentro con
le prova che non può non entrare è
saltato ma le giacche tripudio di sfighe
e niente da mangiare a casa gol pure ma
l'ho toccata ma le carene non ci ha
capito nulla
io non ci posso pensare con salari e non
lo sapevo mai sapeva neanche vuoi
fermarmi 10 secondi però no vabbè dai
dai
bello è fattibile fattibile no no lo
trovate contrario peccato perché questa
era da sempre così horeca in crema o
quella volta lì è strano perché ci credo
sempre questa roba anche se fa gol fatto
sotto detto no vabbè talmente lì è
talmente materialmente li guarda ci sta
ci sta
cielo regista dopo sarei per dividere
due facce per i ragazzi porta gaetano e
sebastiano ragazzi welcome in de giacomo
grazie raga ancora capire se
effettivamente ha senso come la of time
a tuncer si chiama twins air a twins
mamma mia
va bene non sono sempre loro nokia meno
male non è vero mi dissocio e rimane lì
bravissimo perché meno male
vabbè
bravo arrivati due cercato di toccarla
un miliardo è rimasta proprio la nora
gagli l'ho rimesso in mezzo però c'è lo
stesso oggi autrice uno bravo biella
gigi fare mai provare dei livelli di più
il sapere ci si può provare
mamma mia tu sei pazzo importante è che
i comandi sono terribili
ma perché il miglior giocatore al mondo
per quanto mi riguarda non sono
d'accordo
dopotutto i livelli dove lanci mazzette
sulla gente top di socio e chi socio mia
nana nana in ciò che è l'asta spazzata
l'hai vista che trovate alla loro
portano vento sotto l'incrocio ma non
tolta perché questa è la colpa tifate di
andare in attacco l'agenzia lightbox
otteneva bene speriamo
niente nice la volée stoppare e pensavo
nostro passato j ero andato in anticipo
invece era molto più porto
questo è un ottimo passaggio per loro
non male anche il tiro
giovanni rubino e grazie mille per 20
euro dei profeti grado don giovanni ci
hanno fatto non ci ho fatto turbo io non
dovevo
ghirardi lecco fa nate in testa no
[Musica]
e va bene
bravo a servire occhio bellissimo dice
se continuate continuate buonissimo
rimbalzo ma bellissimo ma perché siamo
andati in due siamo partiti
eravamo andati in tre mondo dell'arte 33
creativi le giovanni per altri 20 euro
ieri in volta qualche per chiamate una
grafia i nomi di global games ma in
troveremo discorso educativo con è lo
scopo delle sue mani ma perché sia un
attimo così perché questo lo sa nando
non mi ha dato tanto è un tasto che io
non voglia ce lo dice jack bello grazie
caro la donation un bacino grazie al
supporto ragazzi vengo alla palla io non
ho turbone non posso anche sognare
adesso posso ciao bene potete tirare
ragazzo
no c'è anche questo ok è niente
filo ritoccata lega e lui mi deve rubare
il turbo ma è come hanno fatto essere
genova scusa è successo che chiedevo di
là delle robe che non volevo vedere
capitano di là per caso lega un tocco
che mi ha impensierito non poco
niente chiarito sa bene che rimbalzo
perfetto doppia della zia tanto agi
le coreografie fama e l'altro non
s'aspettavano subito dopo dell'altra
disavanzo ed anche la di questa tecnica
dello stato è così che le sedi che
quando fai cose strane o papà papà
ma per che cosa è male pensavo fossi il
nemico niente non sono riuscito a
toglierla dai vivai della nonna mi sta
bene se abbastanza solo scherzi eh no
chao mai sul palo dopo la vista sul palo
una gara riguardi ha fatto tutto con
calma poi con case sera vado io qua
avevo perso tipo dieci anni di vita
poi entrato
ren
bellissimo ora che con questo la parola
paratoie
no dai tanto sono fastidiosi che palloni
era lei questo è ai fatti non ho capito
[Musica]
è successo che gli è entrato un coro
gospel in carriera quello che campana
che sono prostituta fare qualcosa per
jack bello ti dedichiamo questo gol per
la bella donation da jack grazie jackie
grazie caro nel supporto che bombe tieni
ride e mezzo la vedo un pò troppo che ce
ne frega kitchen in difesa c'è un
aggiornamento non ho capito che l'hanno
fatta la parola step di gara fuori di 10
metri se avessi dato da un riparato
sicuro con l'ostica che ciò l'ha fatto
terra terra
daje daje buono lega ma si cucca ragazzi
a me piace finser allora qui dal tg
caraibi l'aggiornamento è uscito sulla
piattaforma steam non su windows e xbox
quindi siamo ancora carissimi amici a
voi studio arrivederci bellissimo grazie
grazie all'inviato leo che ai caraibi si
aggiorna e si era finito ovviamente non
su steam e massimo zuccato su windows
anche sonagli a ma nel senso che io ero
troppo ero troppo distratto la musica di
sottofondo non ha detto che su steam
funziona su windows mandato non è
possibile tra l'altro perché il gioco è
uno non è possibile tra l'altro non è
possibile tutto questo già veramente
incredibile non ci voglio credere
jack bello un'altra non ne shaw giga
grazie caro del supporto di oggi
grazie mille gara veramente gilbert ti
dedichiamo questa sconfitta se non
doveva essere magari se li riduciamo a
vincerla
ancora meglio la via verso la positività
no no no no sono sempre positivo prima
ha vinto 4 1 dai al bel gol di richiamo
per proclamati da jack questo è un blog
per te toglierlo perché non
forse sì e no mi sta invece che positivo
verde è vero perché ci mette più più
enfasi pensando che andrà già tutto male
sta andando avanti ma che dovevo fare
gol
pino no e in mezzo proprio per la g che
viene colpito ma la palla ancora il
mezzo per l'altra di che viene colpito
però lo stesso e la butta dentro
classici bella storia 4,8 gigabyte e di
aggiornamento su steam ha appena fatto
molto bene
io non ho idea di chi però è sempre off
line
oppure besteam mica solo per noi la para
la parola para la parola para la parata
niente ma no ma no scusate la donation
per la palla che sono stato nation ma e
bisognava del cec bello che fa una mega
donation di 109 99 ma brother grazie
caro che supporter top veramente dato
quest'anno possiamo perdere deriva
dedicata la vittoria alle grande jack
grazie prova delle ragazze del supporto
piace jack grazie abrate è un misto tra
brother e frate mamma mia che tocco come
si è spaventato questo qua è l'ho visto
che la tt installato il gioco
mamma mia come incutono paura via
bersanelli toccavi raramente jackie sei
stato un grandissimo malissimo per the
nation
grazie mille garo
ok tentò questo bel non controllo invece
sì dai e invece no il turno
volevo dire questo importa perché vuole
demolire e vabbè bella mamma mia
il rischio è bello rarissimi la goccia
che una cattiva dello scavo niente eh
vabbè sta sempre nel posto giusto
bravi
agli l'aie riusciamo a uscire da da qua
guardate sisti bravo bros chi no il tema
trito bella no l'abbiamo giocata bene in
realtà momento lui mi frega il turbo
però forse demoliscono demolito neanche
la palla dove bravo lo sapeva tutto
simile vale cavallo ok ragazzi non ci
sono
quanto vale ci sono ok bravo
e va bene non poco più una palla io
signori tutto a posto
era quello che doveva accadere se riesci
anche a toccarla mi fai adesso non
esageriamo di va bene anche così no la
mancata o giustappone no mi dissocio
ma invece palo non si sa come va beh una
volta un po turbo turbo turbo turbo
turbo turbo
non male di peccare bella è una bella
idea
no
e uno mi ha assalito addosso
e allora dai giochi non altro ragazzino
ma che pinch and kings affinche essi
siano con un segno con la bocca mia
[Musica]
mamma mia stessa mamma mia il dato
legato era più che altro per non farlo
tema madame pato bravo a occhio key of
lenta vi prego traversa voleva
attraverso di te la prendi con te ho
fatto un attenzione prossimo quando
metti il filone lago che tenti di
centrare ma la moglie eppure lago e
grosso quanto una porta quindi 13
secondi bastano per loro per pareggiare
ragazze la s anche per vincere mamma mia
io non ho nessun ok ok hanno perso tempo
e ovviamente non tocca è invece ancora
tagli sì non alla mia ragazza che va
verificato quanto sono coccodrillo per
caso se arriva oggi bisogno e 4 di notte
uno qua si si vede che comunque se posso
dire sono un po sotto al 22 però chi
rotation cambia cambia tanto brava
tantissimo grazie ancora giochi bello
per prima tela dedichiamo questa che
dobbiamo fa grazie caro
ma papa no come non ho toccato la palla
bell ha toccato solo che bello amato il
suo liscio mi ha distratto niente tiro
no ma come lo so avaya
la raro battendo la terra ma manda la
vecchia terra così propri casi anche io
il problema che gli avversari ne frega
niente
no allora tocca mamma mi ero convinto
della tua casella di lì a 99 grazie
grazie ai gol di prova bello bello
la saga grazie mille litri e il sat
nell'angolo giusto bravo della questione
senza titoli mirandola si assuma il
controllo delle menti proter bravissimo
di insegne ma diventiamo grand champion
niente attenzione bel gol per il turbo
dall'altra parte bravo non ho turbo ma
ci credo o niente è bella questa mamma
mia
va bene va bene vabbè che grosso è
clamoroso ma anche a rischio anche
perché si era staccata dal muro e la
presento le s scusami stefano gioco
milano lo sai lo dico adesso non è che
sei bravo
sono io quello per colori diversi
aspetta che in realtà le somme ciò
perché siamo noi blu
non che bel gol no dai facciano nominato
un anche la parata come no non era così
nella mia testa e mi avvampa non possono
anche la propria lei
carissimo ma perché non so giocare io
spiegano oggi no ma ho fatto un
controllo che sia uno oggi uno l'ho
fatto e liscio mamma mia
attraverso il nuovo rage perché
attraverso segnala serve per la fanno il
passaggio col club bellone terra sa che
se lui arriva a piazzare ben visto
attraverso così a questo di traverso ok
e lui e da lì una lisciata gli erano
turbo raga sogno non la mette in mezzo è
percorsa applicato quelle già pronto a
tirare grazie jack grazie già calata la
nation da 21 mammamia ragazzo ma oggi i
mega supporter grazie mille garo il
nostro jack che ci supporta live
ma cosa è toccato grazie mille gara
ragazzi dell'amica supporter giochiamo
la macchina nuova
bene mais ma zio ma fatti una vita per
piacere ma perché toglierà o simile a
bam pare mediche sono importanti ma
questa è pericolosa e questo e per jack
questo e per jack
[Musica]
tutto verte jack e grazie al supporto di
ogni lo sapeva lui lo sa aria con un
altro nation lo sapeva grazie jack ogni
core la donation che ci pensino infatti
quattro cabine sono state quattro
mammamia grazie jack davvero mega
supporter
io non so che toccare qua e allora
faccio così e allora fate come volete
[Musica]
hai tra scienza l'iperspazio in quel
niente non so cosa vuol dire quello che
ha detto ma sono d'accordo vantaggio gol
di passaggi incredibile fuori un
driblato dell'arrivo a prenderlo ma ma
così a caso no sono di tutti ormai bel
niente vai di ancora insiste ben
guardato da fermo non so se hai visto
che è cagato fatto vabbè bravo
quest'opera ottimo che l'alterazione
natura alessio bravissimo rabbia colazzo
ormai qua mi saluti un aricolo renzo
fantucci di casadei e te li pellizzaro
il mitico fantuz va bene alessio non ho
capito niente
ho letto quello che ho letto quello che
hai detto perché non ho capito nulla
però pensa verdetto giusto
ho letto quello che hai detto niente
chiamato andrà avanti 2 a divisione e
serve funzionano ma ci sta un
ragionamento a 5gb di cenate di server
di windows ma tu hai visti bene pensate
di perserveranza sono pessimista sensi
pappona su marte spero di no però si sa
e non sa io quello di windows è il
robottino nuovo la nuova missione della
nasa su marte
arriva oggi è una rari lesi di viaggio e
si spiaccicano come io cosa per una
macchina che ci ha messo strumenti ad
arrivare qui aiace bersani a prendere la
macchina ci metterebbe normalità da
nessun marte
ragazzi io non so più cosa dire cioè
jack stai veramente ma che ti devo dire
ma io che ti devo dì ragazzo che titola
menti sta dando ai soldi per la macchina
dopo che la macchina dopo che la rompo
quindi che già gli optional nella
macchina area presi lui
grazie mille jack cosa ti devo dire che
il supporto infinito
l'infinito ti dedico questo questo col
guarda questa alto tirrenico incredibile
come jack però steffe dice si è decisi
togliere grazie pietro si va infatti
stavo perché sta guardando che mi ha
scritto sono dal corso vedere allora
scusate allora pietro è temporaneamente
non va perché ci sono i server in
manutenzione e quindi stiamo aspettando
che torni meno male perché è arrivato in
ritardo però rimane rimani perché
potrebbero tornare on da un secondo
all'altro comunque ti avviso io capisco
io utilizzo di un browser in chat a
figure avviso io cioè tu rimani comunque
rimane lì nei pressi del pressing una
tal nation oggi di una persona che ho
ancora donato si chiama cos'è jack bello
grazie caro un grazie caro grazie caro
del supporto di oggi veramente non so
dirti grazie mio ma come ho tolta bene
la palla
niente comunque ho passato il tempo a
scriverla pietro guardare il telefono si
cazzeggia che lo aiuta nella chat
tutto questo è vero peccato peccato che
non ho subito l'azione no cosa stava
facendo
ormai e tagliate il tiro c'hanno far
altro tiro di la mamma mia mamma mi ha
messo easy grazie jack relazioni legato
a un bel 20 non rassicurante e si vuol
hanno fatto niente sta partita io non ho
fatto nulla
bella la casa della began in lama mia o
di surf a maggio natura la tua anche una
bella casa e poi facciamo guerra di case
adesso kate era costruisce qualcosa che
non sarà più così easy ma allora vuoi
cambiare io ci ho voluto emulare nostro
aggiungendo cose tipo abbiamo fatto un
ponte per fare la zona anche negli
alberi e quindi diventerà brutta per
colpa nostra
poiché la colleghiamo in qualche modo no
ti prego noi nella vita
e invece siamo a 100 metri vera che
pensano e scrivete però ed è sotto terra
a proprio per aggiustare ma era stata
l'albero all'albero coal mine carlton
ora non ci stava e gli facciamo fare una
bella curva possiamo lavorare ci marci
qaeda ma si aspetta aspetta aspetta che
ci sono io
no ragazzi giorni devo io non so trovare
mamma mia che tiro questo pallone
aspetta aspetta niente non so perché io
non sono rimasto importa se facessimo il
quarto casey si rendano quindi lo vorrei
tantissimo è qua qua abbiamo rischiato
di un forte
bello questo tiro di non si può di
rimbalza rimbalza rimbalza nel modo
sbagliato e nuovi ha totalmente
sbagliato così lo zio adriano è arrivato
non se l'è sentita allora taq taq taq
ogni giorno di street
ora che cross bellissimo bellissimo se
non fossi esploso un secondo fase rai si
sia aree volevo tirare in porta se non
ci sono questo partito si nota lo
stupendo
non so se vedete totalmente sai che i
server di si opti visto mi serve un
sentito annunciazioni da
gol come normale caraibi news dei
caraibi niente param param param param
pampararo e vabbè allora hanno giochiamo
perchè c'è da allora chiedo un
collegamento qui da tg caraibi euro
confermare che non ci sono aggiornamenti
ancora in corso passa poi la linea
perciò grazie a tornando per che vanno
up alle 19 30 sì sì certo
ancora attenzione il nodo avevo visto
che sta arrivando addosso però lo fa
niente la cena col palo
ciao ciao diciamo niente ma manda a lato
ma ciò bene bene bravi a reboot e
bisogna mentire di consiglio che assist
a partita
non ho fatto nulla tranne questo tranne
questo tranne questo ragazzi tranne
quello che adesso può sostegno a razzo
rendano magi lei c'è 39 secolo atleti
jimbo e seconda divisione 2
occhio che miccichè che nick è arrivato
il patti sempre dato di fatto di tagli
alle non mi devo passare a diamante due
se non ti fa passare perché ci avrò
qualche non lo so attiva negative
ovviamente non positivo altri appello di
bari o da quello dei pali che mi ami a
casa significa tornare al menu allora me
non mi vedeva davvero non ti vedono
anche io c'ero già stato bravo vita
insieme a torto dopotutto fuori random e
si ci stava dai mantengo il trillo
tagliamolo dunque è stato eliminato
addirittura di sé non è me ne vado non
l'ho fatto io di invito io ho ereditato
non sa che non hanno invitato si arriva
l'invito a non è arrivato e persistenti
diciamo prima è visto quando sono cocco
dannoso con questa nuova skin non
compare in parte non sei paia conti va
beh le scaglie della di riflessi della
crisi
direi chiedero 6 l'ostello coccodrillo
zoe whiteboard nightbirds barba bianca
pensavo lavagna mio vi è quello di one
piece mai vero papà papà turbo ok ok
la donna vorrei timothy insisti mamma
mia che giocatore che giocatore si è
messo il chip per ricordarti come si
gioca il cile skylark sai cosa ragazzi
l'intersse cartella dei dieci skyler che
nei commenti meglio passare alla tua
live diventano a leivi di incontri anche
quelle i pali ma spero solo la mia non è
che mobili soliti gesti te lo giuro io
non so perché
praticamente abbiamo il pane di 19 di
socio mi dissocio
gli dissi mi dissocio da quello che cosa
sto sentendo mi dissocio sempre fatti
avere la samp ho capito ma chi è parata
fatto non ci credo pensavo a toccarsi
cosa succede mi disse no perché case ih
oh mamma mia
comunque no noi siamo tutti amici
daje daje
non ci credo non ci credo ma ove bel
tiro dai 20 romentino complimenti bravo
fa vigeva i complimenti sia veramente un
fenomeno fa dj ma allora villo il
campanello e vanta vito ai ragazzi
braille fatto una cosa incredibile posso
dirlo
peccato che c'era ancora il terzo erano
70 75 persone
bravo a dire tutte le età in zattera che
lo so che non avete tutti i dieci anni
dai ma sì penso che tu stessi scherzando
ma a prescindere da questo non penso
dove dove dalle chat di youtube come
ragazzi mi dissocio me li devo
dissociare da questo basta mutate
quest'uomo sta attento cosa sento mi
dissocio tantissimo ma cos'è radici
basta
è pazzo non si legge più non lei non
leggere quello che scrivono non legge
tournament iii ix e sentire niente
i cdc e dice sì ma cosa sta intense di
aggiornamento dal tg dei caraibi volevo
dire che mi associo anch'io dome è per
forza proprio aggiornamento per
ricordarci che anche il nostro caro leo
si dissocia pensionati
fate le cose così è allacciata ragazzo
basta andare peggio
no non la tolgo staff bravo a ok e cosa
mi è uscito come mamma mia
no allora nice
e bravo lui no della cose strane non lo
so secondo me c'è la macchina fantasma
che compare ogni tanto e allora
filograna welcome in the giacomo
benissimo e vabbè chili di telecom in
the giacomazzi iori gianluca mattevi che
indovina subito di chi si parla quando
viene nominato il gran chip skylark che
niente popò di meno che il cantante foto
più famoso nel mondo ed evacuato i miei
denti e me the line tono ma guarda che
rimbalza non voglio saperlo basta per
prendere anzi no a lezioni messo la
curiosità di da te la canti della grande
gioia tra canti dai grazie non solo
metterla base sarà che potere marchio
piraino proprio bene lui lui non sa
copyright perché lui è superiore ma
anche oltre il compito ok sguardo sono
curioso di sentire di queste tua tv
perché non è che mi ha protetto da
copyright e il copyright che protetto da
chip skylar al contrario
no c'è però la serie la casa in italiano
e chi lo brutto
oddio è va bene ma se c'è una persona
italiana certo che si chiama come
condotto veramente paura di sentire che
cosa tu stia per cantare grande chip
skylark mamma mia top cantante del mondo
e allora la di roma già con questo gol
non lo step
no nessuno la prendiamo loro come minimo
cenno di sì ci ha provato ma veramente
utili in pali non vincere questo 2 a 1
proprio adesso ciò che non fare eccolo è
invece un altro ha girato maglia
mostrerete la macchina la panada dritto
si no
ora va in contropiede il gol bravo lui
non era male e va beh questo sport a
persone bravissimo me l'ha tolta da lì
hai aperto braly no ragazzi
bello questo è pessimo
non è vero va bene forse sì liberate e
allora niente dai giocatori per un tiro
infattibile stati però non so se tolgo
due perché non ho più turbo che non ho
niente ragazzi solo la voglia di vincere
ok allora niente ragazzi e comunque
miliardo di volte ma vi prego vai riparo
sembra in palla
non è mica matti non è mica l'altra tv
fabi fiba utente tipo di tik tok che
faccia il processo
no ma chi evita mente quello che tipo
flip fa tutti i canestri che ti regala
dai la cera vigente certo david e urla
sono certo non lo conosco lo conosco
praticamente ha fatto la prima live
switch è la crisi più bella che abbia
mai visto in vita mia e da quello che ho
capito doveva fare e tirare il dado e
fare proprio 123456 questo tipo 12
ore.quando cd quando a 5 chiama l'amico
che era appena uscita dalla doccia che
ragiona dell'accappatoio e tira riesce
anche se il tipo di smontarli parte il
sorcio penso che si sia capito che mi
dissocio
vado a vedere niente ma non mi interessa
pisello effettivamente effettivamente ma
perché dopo 5 certo dice è uscito perché
intende il 6 è in realtà è uscito altro
capite è bellissima è la clip più bella
di internet
io non posso continuare questi io adesso
sto attenzione era il socio non è nostro
inviato il nostro dissociato lui vada
cercata clip dicono che lì si vede ma
che è cultura
vabbè il rischio via cercare lega ci
fosse una dissociazione con il joystick
anche costretto la mamma mia
matteo di gaetano conte giacomo
matteotti gaetano grazie anche per la
sua nation matteo ripetano direi che
dedico questo gol
favi fibra beta fai come stai potete
chiedermi ma ti seguiamo ti conosciamo
da una vita fabbri se sei tu fabrizio
grande rapper marlin commenta giacomo
caro e niente rimango qua e niente due
hanno fatto un bel gol drag azione
bella cantante né difesa quindi a noti
si narra che bravi nel 2013 per noi
porca miseria era vamo chiellini
cannavaro è sistemato al contrario però
ppp e vabbè allora niente scusa stefani
ma solo e l'ho toccata così non madonna
mia meno male che la recuperiamo ma è
bello aspetta bravo la tiro io non la
tiro più un io se la toccavo no perché
al centro e bellissima
non ci credo come me l'ha toccata altro
mi sono girato bravo grande se non sei
da solo taggato bravo bravissimo nulla
perché sa benissimo che tocco magico ma
g card che poi blu contro blu non si
capiscono e non ha capito il mio credo
che io primati accidentato in pieno ho
capito perché è una tesi a c'è da dire
che togli
attenzione anche agli avversari e quindi
da fare una tv dove di cantare la
canzone ancora
ma la signora massimo che posso cantare
la sua in inglese regala non so se ti
cambia gli italiano sola studi tornello
giusto
bhatti ma perché non esiste oggi nel
controllo
niente in chat e parlano della clip e
cioè evelina mi aspettavo parlare di
vero
io cerco sempre di non parlare di stand
in ogni bene aperti ma perché non amare
perché stavo ridendo perché non mi si
spezza più la palla davanti come creta
minuti per tirare spritz no come lo
script sarà però strizza la pretty he
aperitivo è questa la feriti questo
punto e questo non era perché mi sono
sbagliato però questa non è male se per
caso alcuni voi ci crede è rimasta lì la
di là di ala bilanci la pa pa pa
no no rega regala norica bravi che
coniuga una ragazza è vero non regga fra
vino e pasta vino
bravissimo bello bello
no rimbalza bene questa miss a nome loro
amica era l'avevo vista stavano sul
turno
[Musica]
penso ha detto poi per scontato che che
saresti riuscì tutti parlano di niente
avevo fatto io ho voluto sono stato
l'inutilità ho fatto niente praticamente
pagato io malissimo
siamo calati ma cosa c'è e non ha visto
la clip pensa veramente vista ma dai
dovevo andare niente fabian imploro dal
fronte si ortis dai ragazzi dai dai
ragazzi questi qua ma per favore
leo aggiornamenti dal tg caraibi ancora
nulla
una buona linea grazie niente da fare
ragazzi tg caraibi ci siete al centro e
si no tutta da buttare tutta votata la
porta a porta l'ha portato a quattro
ruote portava da qui dai nota purtroppo
talvolta avuto ha avuto e ha guadagnati
buttava potevo andavo trovi ciarlare
capacità buttava la punta non ha trovato
nessuno che l'ha attaccata in mezzo a
due ore che sta in mezzo a guardare e
allora pilot io non ci posso credere
nega mi dispiace non mi son caduto del
settore che abbiamo pressato partita
comunque con dei gol cioè al mentre
visti gol su quattro abbiamo presi c'è
il maniera imbarazzante quasi 5 pensate
ma pensavamo quindi fatemi capire se
ortiz e funziona solo su steam non su
quello che ho capito io è uscito
l'aggiornamento su steam e si può
scaricare però non so se serve
funzionano mentre su microsoft non è
neanche uscito l'aggiornamento per il
momento da quello che ho capito io devo
letame sì che teheran 3 voti che oppure
no e sushi viaggio 20 su steam
ma a sto punto credo anche su windows
non è tanto quello il problema problema
suoi server
aggiornamento che scinde in due ore e
vediamo se riusciamo a se ne separava
mai
sergio aveto grigio
vabbè dai testi che capiamo ma vi
aggiorno cosa la musichetta appena so
qualcosa ma l'italia grazie leo
sembrerò inviato ai caraibi che
quest'anno popolo ci può solo rimanere
ma man mano che passano pure a gradara
io non prima prima deve farmi la
carbonara e la matriciana comunque che
aveva promesso poi può andare ai caraibi
gli devo parlare con della megaride po
di sabbia rischiamo però magari comunque
hanno una connessione migliore di
mappano a quello senza mamma mia non se
l'aspetta una m'aspettavo manco i fatti
ho detto
scusate i ragazzi e tranquillo broschi
ci penso io
bellissima mamma mia come se risalto a
tutti e tre si dà solo siete da soli per
evitare che altro di conte pelle la
felpa che hai l'ho vista adesso è vista
è veramente troppo bello seguivo la
maglietta così uguale proprio cioè
quando la mente
andiamo andiamo in centro vedi come cd
mitomane letti ma dove siete libera
riace daffy duck al 2 dei nel nome da fu
ucciso e non è un caso ragazzo o la di
il rischio mamma mia
ribatte nel modo giusto mamma mia perché
non esiste ma perché allora niente
ok ok lo si è visto ma con la linea
ucciso
guarda che questo abbiamo una bellissima
mamma mia mamma mi ha spinto nola
bloccato riuscito
pensavo che lui e andasse a tirare per
cielo l'avevo già saltato ma non ci
arriva con lo sfondo meno male bravo ok
è molto corta e bravissimo sei tu hai
d'equipe a mamma mia alex 2009 grazie
per non sentirne però non ci voglio
credere
note o quasi
mamma mia la di da solo contro 16 ancora
lunga questo si chiama tv è la vinci
bravo omissata e delimitarlo preso in
pieno il tipo garda bravissimo da aj non
ci credo però tele taglio stamani maya e
lì ancora rimbalza non c'è la stessa
cosa mia mamma quando giocavo troppa
play quando ero piccola che noi lo
stesso ho chiesto le minacce che ti
faceva così da poterle e allora niente
ragazzi veramente fatto una cacata io
cerco di rimediare ma non posso che
mossa da parte di colori teorema che
macchina era ragazzi e una twiss no tu
in ser
non può che si chiama scusate ho detto
la parola quella c è nel canale anche
l'istituto ho detto
cacchio con les cultures come cacchio si
chiama mecca che faccio a camminare con
la cacca
twister tweenies the twisters twins e
twins e non potete sul rennes dare per
me chi dice che questa macchina è più
brutte le lotte non capisce una mazza si
guarda che c hai cosi come si chiamano i
soul si apprende descritta bene e
sistemi sun blue screen degli occhi
velati incredibile e l'altro della sua
grande descrizione ce l'ho proprio vista
e leghisti questi due sono visti bene
questi due soste aspetta questo aspetto
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta un
secondo di pausa più l'acqua che finiva
mai sparite vedere il mare insomma è
niente
www comunque dalla ministra stiamo
andando bene
pensiamo di sicura più in che l'uso non
solo di quante premente o due o tre tipo
non succede mai la mattina con la dicono
siamo solo noi due ma ormai siamo saliti
a un run che per me è troppo alto per la
dino perché la diceva se la legge da
aggiustare io no 06 mai chiedono in due
culture sono un po il blocco sono
arrivato quasi al limite per l'editoria
sì tanto quello che segna anche
chiaramente a giocare vincita is gone lo
continuiamo domenica mattina
non vedo l'ora tra l'altro troppo bello
tu hai mai giocato però per caso dei gol
no marcelo gratis perché con la play 5
lo davano free livello tra loro anche in
solo perché è veramente una bella
esperienza videoludica è infatti
sembrava figo figo e poi molto per word
vera è praticamente della stoffa e
curato come della stoffa due open world
però sto riassumendo molto manieri e di
cinema immagina storia un pochino più
brutta perché essere a quel livello è
difficile
ti dico io o 6 ore di gioco quindi per
il momento non ti posso dire grandi cose
propri momento anche la storia sembra
interessante che effettivamente non è ai
livelli di the last hope altri momento
però gli zombie che sono sempre in un
modo o nell'altro avranno fatto 425
giochi con zombie ma continuano a
piacermi la cosa bella che difensive la
sua fase le orde di infettino si schermo
milioni di infetti che ti inseguono
media che era incredibile quello ho
scoperto claudio vincenzo spettacolo non
sapevo pro.di.pi la prossima volta farò
attenzione alla voce pop e quelli per il
campo ok non l'ha detto latino aveva una
bottiglia d'acqua da 18 litri a per
quello che ci sta mettendo un po sono
guardi hanno trovate viene dovuto
riempirlo che penso non fossero piace
aleksander cancellare notifiche per
piacere voi siete gentili con le vostre
lex finanzierà e non è che io ce l'ho
mai staccata proprio pensa quanto la uso
però sono abbastanza gentile con alexa
signori in effetti è terribile di
valextra spedita perché se povera donna
esatto cioè questa era meglio anche se è
un intelligenza artificiale delle merita
rispetto
anche secondo me infatti tratto bene il
robottino quello che pulisce per terra
quello che separa la polvere che si
chiama spolverino perché un robottino
asta toglie la polvere ha pure il nome
di matisse anche che il mio gatto lo
torna forse è stato meglio alexa che il
mio gatto
ti ricordi altra volta che è venuto a
fare ho sentito che ho detto che tratto
meglio all extra che il mio gatto ma non
è vero dai ma lo sai bene la farà
penso che il tuo gatto sia più bassa del
mondo si affaccia con un trattato bene
lucia grazioli è rovinata era lui
proprio lui la mutata potete fare da
terra sì lì a far avere unica della
prossima settimana teoricamente e questo
forse gol
invece no vabbè bravi loro mamma mia
mamma mia mi sono veramente cacato è
niente bravo allora dài niente ancora ma
quindi è solo in difesa allora in
attacco c'erano modalità pro 5 minuti
che devi vele
mi piace non la può missare lui non la
pomì sarà perfetto continuano ok
almeno è arrivata dall altra parte per
la prima volta miss matt o no perché se
n'è accorto lui che è bravo non io che
sono scarso solo diamante 2 su ok
e allora e allora allora pregati pregati
punti tutti gioca tutto un peccato
guarda che questa rimbalzo in modo che
non riesco a prendere mai nella vita ci
credo ma se camera calora ragazzi di
sempre allora ragazzi non mi fate fare
questa vita
ok la polizia 9 di tutte le cose
lg a carol bartolomeo di martino e non
benissimo potuto dire tutto
voi capite gioco un campo di marte carol
no
meno male che la mia è stata eravamo
tutti in retromarcia tra l'altro per
prendere la palla bravo poi ha iniziato
a giocare a ieri anch'io non sono da
meglio però dai pizzata ma io lo sto
vedendo dove la palla signori adesso la
vedo e posso tirare che però non importa
vabbè aspetta niente fino ai noti sì 6
no e questo è successo
scusatemi dalla mia visuale era
incredibile c'è questo 4 gatto la palla
e poi scomparsa anche nella mia visuale
quindi da server rack l'aquila colpita
l'aveva veramente colpita si sino in poi
non se non si è capito
ok vai vai vai 9 hanno fatto di brutto
per capelli anticiparli vieni tieniteli
bello di nonna stavo togliendo la
supertop nome al lancio nero giallo o
male male bellissimo guarda che bello
che non sapevo esistesse tipo un sole
buco nero bonico cerchiamo di non
vederlo mai più però mai vero
eccolo è già pronto io ho provato a
intercettarla non sono riuscito a
ragazzi dai 2 qualcosina ma perché è
bello per tre minuti e mezzo abbiamo
preso con cui ama da morire mi dispiace
quando uno ha un bel una bella soltanto
del gol
voglio rivederla fabio pam tutti siamo
andati tutti senza un motivo
sei partito da dietro sinora infatti
l'ho detto io per sbaglio c'e la scarica
la colpa è mia qui perché però voluto
urlare come se non avessi gol bravo fa
vj bravo bravo magari non applaude
mentre c'è una falla quali mani questo
ed è bravo
[Musica]
hai lasciato già fatto sei caduto
proprio il basso fa vie ma perché a
volare io sto gioco capisci che non devo
proprio fare la sua terra l'appalto
rasoterra perché se non riesco a giocare
volando gioco insomma no mamma mia mamma
mia
la beffa arriva l'altra
questo lo potevo sbagliarla anche se
sono rimasto senza fiato tutto il tempo
che andava davvero senza fiato noi
speriamo più curato e siano rosicato un
po troppo tardissimo o contributo che
questa partita essenziale prima di 176
punti però il coccodrillo si fa vedere
mister lento comunque stava arrivando
pian piano sono diamante del gabbiano 6
arrivando anche il diamante 3 pure
qualche stesso anche se più difficile
anche se è più difficile giocare in 33
siamo ovunque scalando la classifica
ragazzi non è male perché perché oggi
dovevamo master dei pirati ma vabbè ma
se voi mi metto il cappellino da pirata
secondo posto non ci sono alle barche al
costo delle auto per giocare gara dopo
se esci ti rimette il cappellino da
pirata così almeno abbiamo un po di aids
e cacciò papà papà papà
ma papa ma non se la strada ce la farà
tu volevi bloccarmi però ora che nessuno
dei due l'ha presa diretto vabbè ormai
troppo tardi guardala ha pubblicato
vabbè allora scartato puoi tirarlo
all'angolino destro no vabbè non ci sta
credendo a posto in giro clamoroso
mammamia stesso brava mamma mia la di
mamma mia ragazzi segnare tantissimo
si vabbè lo demolito un'ora dopo che lo
demolito era bravo ma perché scusate ok
ciao anticipo dalla tv lo show mia madre
iniziato la faccia in tutto questo
bello bello tutto oneste ragazzo volete
chip skylar moment vai vai vai vai
non parte qual è la crisi della lever
palcoscenico di ieri massimo silenzio
suddetta cosa aspetta
due nomi li do hoon lee sarda che mi fa
ma se comincia l'era dei capi ma john mi
bacia la marcia di tutto rispetto al
giudice massei baciani take two suns
jones litetrace messi di nuovo ma
justice e misma maccianti mi associo di
difendere ma cianci cosa slice machalik
isner spacco a giudizio mafer marcia di
tweet the place saint just like
christmas una work ma già su simili
smart lasciati dai passanti i tempi
baciami kate
[Musica]
era stato bravo un contento di averla
sentita solo per la tua interpretazione
perché comunque non la conoscevo grazie
grazie veramente i miei complimenti
grazie a tutti io non so perché parlo
youtuber cantante
aggiornamento da tg caraibi arrivano i
complimenti anche da qui sta il
bravissimo cantante grazie al chip
skylark e quando voi in italiano sarebbe
i miei denti me scintillano come le
stelle in cielo non prendono mai tartaro
le carie è qualcos'altro illuminano al
mondo come a natale quando la gente in
paradiso con un sorriso tra i con i
denti a mente queste lingue in italiano
in più o meno era così ma la cosa
la cosa sconvolgente che tu che comunque
è imparato questo testo a memoria
cerello migliaia di bambini e si
distinse sarò infatti c'erano mistica di
cui però tu lo sei comunque a memoria
questo tipo o no grazie grazie
spesso ti fa onore conferma il fatto che
comunque è una parte del cervello
dedicata se tu chiedi all'altra di
quest'arte ti fai vedere questo pezzo
che quando l'ok libano gli domandi
all'altra di l'altra di lhasa meglio dei
membri immagine lo giuro l'immagine
l'immagine di velardi che andiamo a
scuola alle medie
allora la prima volta che ci vediamo ti
prego ne ho bisogno di te se si deve
comparirvi alle tutte e due
e lui non lo sa in inglese ha peccato in
italia quando cantiamo in italiano e
allora niente siamo oltre la cena regola
c'è la regola non posso muovermi non mi
posso muovere lega noi posso più muovere
non mi posso muovere ci hanno vampata ok
hanno spezzato loro l'incantesimo non mi
potevo muovere non ragazzi quand'è così
non ci si può muovere questa è la regola
capita raramente ma va rispettata è
ricordato i ragazzi mi raccomando fate i
seri e allora via
pa pa pa pa pa adesso questa a prenderla
non riesco a prenderla non posso ma che
per i voli dal muro e niente nodi che ci
sei vero brava eccolo porta interessa
che sta importa qualcuno che tira io che
ha fatto si diceva bene è rimbalzata a
me alla fine mi piacerebbe poter dire
che era programmato ma sono veramente
scarse mammamia palo paolo niente niente
niente
c'è chi dice che c'è chi dice che uno
che canta in italiano uno che canta in
inglese eric in che lingua calabrese
così nichi e mezzo marian breve quindi
si può fare ma per fare un po di
istituzione prima e mezzo sardo per mi
dimentico sempre mezzo siciliano mezzo
calabrese mezzo sardo mezzo libro via
genitori si erano i miei nonni aria un
po più conosciuti ancora ad uno i miei
nonni faccio la luce da un sacco di
tempo e vediamo
facevo mamma mia che parata dello stesso
bellissimo rivista il bello raccogliendo
10 minuti vedevo abbandonata pensavo
peccato e che ci crede o legge che ci
hanno problemi così di nera intanto
guarda stanno usando la stessa sia
dell'acquisizione uso io dai un bacino
ea non sta andando adesso no
gli uomini di stoffa cose buono questo
non ne va male questo non è male la diva
proprio loro che dico così fini che
ricade peak of the monnalisa esau
ragazzi questo lo deve farci ciò il suo
margine marino perché ciccio alzo dice
solo questo non entra sul mio forma
chissà che cacchio proprio livelli è
facile assegnato loro un tocco
imbarazzante ho detto malate gli atti
non acceca apposta te lo giuro che ho
pensato è dura non facilmente facciamo
così non solo toccata ho detto chi non
sa cioè gag uno se l'aspetta mai
bellissimo ma sono pericolosissime nodi
scusato insomma quando noi
[Musica]
mamma mia roma ci ha tolto a te www le
fatto una cosa clamorosa e non potevo
toccarlo ma totti era andato per
spararla ma questo qua arrivato il volo
aveva perché bene o meno
bravissime la messa ha dovuto devo
levare una secondo me doveva
posizionarmi meglio ma da come era
posizionato quest'anno la toglievo
maicon e tiro ak si si non l'avevo
preparata bravissimo io con i miei zero
punti devo dire che abbiamo
no assolutamente no vabbè altro stato su
di lui
bello scusatemi la cavo si no
c'entra volta bravissimo sguardo turchi
vuoto motta
la neo mamma mia se non la toglievano
questi qua da mente va bene bravo lui
filosofia che anima gli agenti
atmosferici ma perché si possono
togliere gli agenti atmosferici tipo la
pioggia mangiano anche fatto che va a
influire veramente sul le prestazioni
insieme saranno i nomadi veramente pochi
colpa mia scusatemi non so come
veramente non so come io non abbia tolta
cioè le mafie passaggio a random ha
fatto dentro la porta ecco perché ne ho
cliccato la cantate di falco mysanity
termici skylar ti autorizzo metto lo
vedono quello tributano in questo caso
sono in questo
[Musica]
[Risate]
la parola canada e ventola vissini lega
richiamo di chiamarla mai shin'ichi
tellme chip skylark over bike ride
comunque cosa che stavo dicendo mi sono
dimenticato
magari parlando del agenti atmosferici
di a si va beh ma non è che vanno a pesa
così tanto sulla certo un conto è se c'è
un gioco dei devero indirizza lerma
lontanissima tipo play erano un pub gvg
come gracchi si pronuncia
quindi non la tieni perché chi se ne
frega però qua a picco non è che secondo
me non cambia niente
ma il mio discorso era ma va a influire
effettivamente sul gameplay nel senso
cioè 96 fatah scivoli di più per dire no
figurati no semplicemente una questione
di scheda grafica secondo me che
comunque se c'è la scheda che meno
grafica pro ma io intendo proprio di
gameplay c'avevo di rocket no no no no
non lo fa sì che la pratica ci siamo
secondo me non lo fa non ho mai a dovevo
parlare doveva andarci doveva andare
doveva andare prima ragazzi che se non
avete va troppo alto e devo sperare una
mente stata troppo a destra perché se
non saltavo liberamente volta e non a
prendere comunque mannaia il router per
eccellenza al comune prendere mio passo
non tributate lega fora che chiedere il
permesso una cosa di bello e non posso
ne va bene ti tolgo lega se dite voi è
già pronto
la stoppa l'anticipo
l'amoroso questo è peccato
ok dai non ci crederà mai nella mia vita
ragazzi è incredibile traversa
pazzesco hanno preso anche loro erano
poi sia nato male io devo stare molto
più forti
non ci credo ok bene fai niente
come potevo anche come poteva una
portata o mortai ha portato severa se
per caso la toccavo st palla qua è
niente di che natura gatti si ok un
attimino se riesco no no tratterà casa
un pari collegate al va bene di blog
serve a niente l'album dell'area non lo
faccio la mamma mia è bravo lui mi ha
spazzato a tutti attenzione che colori
parte come una saetta la manca cosa
succede
non è vero se ti prego di togliere
questa roba
occhio che tira nichi è la di che può
pararla
ora che me la mette nell'angolino
opposto ha vinto il rimpallo e guarda
che tiro che ha fatto sto qua che io ero
proprio in mezzo se togliamo doveva
nell'angolino malefico vi prego anche vi
pregherei proprio niente perché serve un
miracolo più che una preghiera qua
insomma niente così
peccato perché erano fatti peccato se si
erano battuti christine delle macchine
comunque azzurro dell'inter ero allora
mi dissocio io perché sa perché sono
nell'inter e nel gioco se ci pensi mì
tanto dice inter entrato in uscita era
però io vi saluto va a scapito di scacco
lo va bene accordino vanno a scaccola un
po bene grazie essere passato non sono
cambiate tantissimo con te aspettate la
che aspettate che mi metto start cup e
sono partito ieri il cappello
non so non so se purtroppo prima delle 8
guardano vadano ma io mi sa che non si
era mai vista chiara che quelli che va
no ormai guarda
tanto per soft ci giocherà al mio
aspetta un aggiornamento
allora qui dal tg caraibi è disponibile
aggiornamento su microsoft store grazie
e arrivederci e quindi vorrebbe tanto
tata e finisce se sei veramente tagliata
inventato incredibile comunque cosa devo
dire
ma questo nuovo via cristian e siamo
online solo che lecito aggiornamento su
microsoft va bene sono proprio contento
di giocare a fi allenamento 51 giga
scuse va bene dice luca che non c'era
grazie dark alex grazie mille
mamma mia barca l'ex grazie caro
comunque le ma è un aggiornamento
importante ci stanno aggiungendo europa
o in oro ma soltanto ora basta ci sono
tante fatti li ha fatti cioè se non c'è
niente
ora sarebbe l'ora di fare aggiornamento
interessanti che ci sta giocando un
sacco di gente ma voglio spiegare che
stava si sono 1
la si sono una che ci son già starsene
fatto il partner ma veramente non è
cambiato niente la prima ma giocando
sali di livello dell'anno skin roba
ma dai due nessuno entrati due è
comunque affidate al fallimento
quest'anno le cose
le nuove che fattiva avrei fatto che
oggi nel caso
e invece e invece babbo va bene le app
rossino camerata del turbo occhio dati
ragazza a lui magra miseria ma porca
pasca porical e ancora per la donation
bros chi no sono bravo bravo
lasciate non ci credo dai ragazzi
se hai una barzelletta e tra detto
lasciate proprio nel momento in cui la
stavo toccando neeson tipo risucchiato
del ruotolo
niente colore deve essere buono e lo
stesso evitate soldi
qui è tutto sotto controllo andare
contro sotto controllo della ge che però
non si state all'ultimo cielo s'è presa
si si si io ho visto con tolto perché
lui ha attirato vero tutta tira io
guarda ha tirato addosso è bellissimo il
gol e dobbiamo fare tre volte avviso
anche scacco lato
la soddisfazione bene bene bene nel
cervello è più piccolo adesso già arabi
tutti stiamo andando ok alcuni non
importa
tutti visite barbati con loro bene bravo
è stato forte lui e infatti ho fatto io
quello che avrebbe dovuto fare lui sa
che peccato
[Musica]
guardo ragazzi in attimo lo ricordiamo
non è gol
bene bene mattina ai sapevo lo sapevo e
ho umanissimo york che palline ok per
dire essere anche palla sibila palla
questa bellissima mamma mia
bravi si dicono che mette in macchina o
di rom
il bello però detto ancora si si lo
faccio proprio
del city e niente vediamo per queste
cose di toccarlo allora vai aiuto è
falso è pazzo ma fiat è venuta di più di
giocare pensavo portato comitato che mi
han dato il sangue al cervello per un
attimo sono giuro ho avuto un mancamento
niente basta questo è più abituato
proroga non so se lei bravissimo uno più
turbo
io ho paura di questi ultimi tre anni
staccando gli occhi lega fatti scusatemi
un attimo però devo prendere questo gol
in armonia
ok diciamo che è mangiati così il tiro o
comunque può prendere tempo tac aleggia
la o primo colpo fa così arrivare la
palla però era era meglio che era meglio
farlo a toccare a sto punto qualche bel
gol ma va via nave a mamma mia per una
volta è successo è successo è successo
mi dissocio perché succede a noi di
solito sta roba
pazzesco mamma mia incredibile mori
avere una volta è successo a noi c'è il
positivo dark alex grazie red one nation
carotideo grazie mille brava del per il
supporto e voi come anche in de giacomo
grazie caro cosa mi sono letto subito
però stavamo concentrati ti dedichiamo
questa bella vittoria caro trovato nov
il papa è quello bianco titanio che
costa 200 euro casa poiché quanto cosa
sia ma poi trovare la gara e la via
questo basta niente dare buttano di
realtà quanto passa la mia che ho
trovato prima importata ti pare a
causarla considera praticamente farà
schifo sicuro peccatore che vuole molto
bella che non serve magari a trovata no
ragazzi su counter strike ci sono gli
skin che costano
migliaia di euro non possono saperlo
mamma mia quello è quello è un fenomeno
c'era il tipo di mezzo ma fatto ci sono
anche togliere una pensate fatto uscire
una pace per le tg mamma mia ragazzi
come abbiamo preso con noi non lo so ma
area e ridicola ridicola ridicola dato
quello lì stava lì chi lavora pure
scappare è proprio ridicolo ma devo
partire o no ma ha fregato il turbo
bravo rimbalzo perché è salito cavi
siamo tutti qua amici se ripartono
casinò dove non importa che non so io
non potevo levarla perché c'era potuto
sono girato ho visto che sta arrivando
miss online perché eravamo tutti avanti
io potevo levare potevo sotto forse
rischiavo scandalo rischiavo rischiavo
fischiava era di giocare
va bene va bene va bene gli diamo no
ragazzi e impastata mente miss bello ti
aspetto
la colpisce gli utente lui niente non si
può toccare
vabbè dai allora sarà salato madonna è
stato stata un'incomprensione devastante
ci stiamo ad eliminarti wasted uscito
fuori nice
no ok ok era giusto sì sì bello è
l'unico modo per toglierla ho rischiato
ma non potevo fare niente niente al
ragazzo che quando anch'io non stiamo
giocando se facciamo stiamo cercando
questo partito è rimbalzata proprio male
ok siamo salvi per ora anche allora
andate a male rimbalzo anticipato ma te
lo dico io ce l'ho io ce l'ho io 8
macchina questa 60 centrale ma perché
perché perché ho però niente ragazzi
niente mi sociale tra correnti però non
staccare sto gioco
fatemi staccare starò che io non ve la
sera della cena rotta bravo la curva s
brutta brutta al centro ha centrato il
coach foschi grazie caro no grazie per
il parma sia grazie caro grazie mille
bel commento brother
macché recuperabili si no certo bello di
così tiro io giocavo
[Musica]
niente scene delle catene si sa conta
quella vuol dire fatto la scelta giusta
ma perché usa dire un altro un altro
bravi
no no no no sì sì sì sì mammamia ragazzo
lo stock o l'ho fatto che fanno questo
per sognare o due o tre volte per ogni
cosa ci si vede infatti settembre 2000
non so come prima che gli crea usi
guarda libera mio mia regione è una
città meno
insomma 16 libera dell'auto che sarebbe
la texture dell'auto ok dell'esotica
gaia la vedo io andavo i tre ma una
volta pensa c'era guarda gli aranci
capito è sempre il carnevale degli
aranci si prende ritirano le arance
addosso io ero andato che lo avevo sei
anni ho preso una lancia in faccia poi
tornato cielo rezzato un bel po noi no
spegniamo scala per cortesia
io non posso crederci ragazzi io
veramente non ci va cancellata fate
finta che non esista questa parte di
vita ok noi le 18 e 41 del 2021 di del
18 febbraio non le abbiamo vissute
ok non sono mai non sono mai realmente
accaduto e quindi ragazzino dire che no
io ho tirato grazie a un rimpallo e lui
lo sapeva comunque sia praticato
grazioli in ballo ed era lì pronto
spararla vado come noi parte vincere
questa partita sarebbe veramente un
insulto cioè come cimeli guarda se
vinciamo ci rendiamo perché non esiste
staccata fanno solo bene
e l'indicazione che fate le cose insieme
niente gli ha assegnato gli rovescia
ragazzi bastava basta per cortesia
usciamo che non voglio neanche vivere
guarda guarda guarda dal siculo ma che
partita è foschi che ha stilato nation
non ce la meritavamo da solo ma che
partita e questi risultano il centre
avete giocato ma dai ma dai uno era 13
regata
ma siamo noi vabbè loro loro mamma mia
raga ma comunque al carnevale d'ivrea
praticamente passano i carri condivide
il carnevale no però non ci sono le robe
cioè tipo sa i tipi draghi colorate ne
avevamo già parlato in live di una
cagata viene corso e sempre con le
ragazze una lancia al posto di draghi
c'è tipo un container fatto a mega
contenitore con dentro tipo tutte le
arance del mondo sisvel e tirano esatto
e sopra sopra i container ci sono dei
ragazzi che le lanciano è tornati per
farmi lasciare la rai faccia perché non
avevo mai se non sbaglio paghi anche per
stare sul caso e se si prendono l'occhio
paghi di più è di ba.si moltiplicatore
dei punti
oggi è perfetta per due mister
gustinetti vita la pessima prova il
piemonte è una regione incredibile piena
di cultura è la vedi arancio e di
arancia i posti grazie caro guarda che
crossing
ma come faccio adesso non a torto come
non so cosa la blocca foschi grazie
mille ancora per l'altro non action
super supporter anche tu oggi è se non
la toccava era pericolosi sia per loro
però porta porta rai perché era il
contrario
[Musica]
no è il canto per loro è finita no
la miseria ordina miseria porca porca
miseria tocca miseria regalo bello persa
così siamo
ma perché perché non ho calcolato niente
ecco perché matematica facevo schifo
no ragazzi bravo 98 dal turbo non ci
posso credere non ho mai bella palo
esploso anche un bel stato bravo a
fermarmi ma sarebbero questo è veramente
pessimo per l'attenzione
ecco guarda io non vedo gli altri quindi
pensavo mi avesse caricato quando non mi
caricano fece sapere la cosa opposta
sempre opposta quando non mi caricano
non vado quando incaricano vado e lo
sbaglio incredibile no no i legali
madonna lo tocca
ragazzi vi prego guardate come entrata
st palla guardate come entrata st palla
per favore guardate me vera guarda
adesso mi batteva come non l'ho toccata
rosa come non l'ho toccata non lo so è
imposta è veramente una sfiga io sono di
braida che parla il carnevale con
l'arancia non lo fanno più a si no
magari perché è per la sito no perché la
tradizione troppo lunga così non si può
bloccare anche come bloccare il calcio
storico fiorentino
senza una razza in pazza non puoi
giocare non vivi dell'anno ma almeno poi
fanno le spremute o neanche usano le
rate senza sangue non ho la minima idea
vi sono particolari source foschi grazie
caro
e patapim e patta fame patapim e patapam
e patapum e patate niente perché alla
fine della sua scorta troppo bene bene
bene bene bene bene bene ed eccolo tra i
ragazzi e la verità qualche non ci
stiamo impegnando le abbiamo vinte
giocare per cifre ma papà ti va bene se
solo riuscissimo a coordinarci di più
fidati così ed eccolo filati che
speriamo dai due minuti di ragazzi due
minuti e la socia sul gizio thank you
might non ha capito gliè chiedevo ma te
di essere salutato nella città da me è
un grandissimo fan ti prego salute è uno
appena scrivono una persona che si
chiama mister doctor ha appena scritto
un qualcosa su di te ne la mia chat che
è la fronda fatte vedere a steve il mio
video il figlio di steve fr
ci tengo tantissimo a comunque verranno
venire gli sconti virginio cosa lo
sapevo ero in pieno lo sapevo lo sapevo
lo sapevo che non ci ho dormito due
notti oppure si può non avvertire in
virginia e g il genio virginio
parlamento di regia
[Risate]
mamma mia mamma mia
foschi grazie che per essere passate
grazie del supporto caro bello queste
cose io comunque non era comunque sul
palo profit
sì sì nel dubbio quello mi voleva bene
casa giocate molto bello no reagan o no
non so se avete visto cosa ho fatto
forse è meglio così no stop contro
l'aquila non è vero ma no la vuoi come
giacomo gara niente 4 una mano e palo
che per loro quanto pare ragazzi questo
è un segno no mamma mia che giro che è
un fatto bellissimo però è ovvio che c'è
il terzo fu attenzione e niente porco
demonio è tolta lega non si può togliere
ma non accettiamo ragazzi già focus
sante marchigiane che ios
vediamo di fare un bel focus perché
chiede ora in che squadra siete anche
navale di libere ha sempre a squadre il
carnevale di vivere libere della
fiorentina non ha idea delle sposate
recanati ventina gli era stata una volta
ma lo aspetta cazzate tipo sono pazzi
sono pazzi sono pazzi sono pazzi guarda
questa roba
ragazzi vi prego non suren date ora pare
che no ma l'hanno fatto apposta
non credo no brutta brutta da ragazzo
che perché hitchens di sac ha lanciato
il joystick e quando è successo sta roba
quindi perché abbiamo tutti abbiamo
secondi per fare due gol di kick off ha
posto tre pianeta
mamma mia cosa ho tolto per comunque il
porto ieri la juve riuscito a fare due
gol di kick off
oddio no ma dai non serve un caso quello
che ho fatto per ormai almeno per la
bandiera questo comprendiamo lo aspetta
che la tocco ecco che si sa cosa è
successo non fate una cosa che se non la
prende la valuta russa ma che il che
cambia youtube e lo stesso steve
carnevale si fa con le persone nude
ok li socio grazie inter nos comunque
glielo detto bello sto carnevale ma
perché se usato uno italiano bene lo sa
non penso sia vero che non prende le
valute fruste organizza la valuta russa
non penso penso che mi viene internata
così regale forse ne frega
la tanto france la tanto pon pon usl e
forse queste da vice a questa è la vince
a questa piscia e da vinci ha subito le
stesse un cast ben la gente lo sa le
frazioni pet di pete travis bravi de
france e regale francia o fino al molo
fino al molo e forti le partite prepara
già la canzone materassi materassi e
opel esco da portò le famiglie questa da
vincere ai ragazzi questo video youtube
questo video dedicato ragazzi che se
youtube e ragazzi si vince questa
partita non si perde se non posso
mettere attenzione ma pato ancora papi
il fabi che tiro schifoso le forze le
partenze nel reparto delle forze e
attenzione ai per faber beach box
la ciofeca mare della rete
attenzione attenzione la reparto e il
favi portiere non tolta mese fa ma che
schifo ragazzi straface il punteggio da
schifo da ripartire un po il mio video
dai basta allora come fa vincere che
tenta di dio e non potevo farla lo
babette atteso niente o le francesine
forte è perché si vede dice stampa
premier dovrà per forza gol perché sono
il video non è non è in città capi e il
momento ragazzi ci siete aggiornamento
online signori ai mutui stagione e wi fi
watch v frigo materazzi è caduta quale
si sono belve dall asl e non lo so
questa canzone chiuso solo un ritornello
perché sono molto snello io faccio i
video belli qui proprio su youtube è
caduto perché ha preso una testata causa
della crisi l'attività
abbiamo preso un gol da schifo perché
facciamo proprio schifo non vinciamo
raimondi signori adesso ridacci la
nostra giocosi perché siamo noi i
campioni del mondo è nostra e nostra
vogliamo la gioconda a leo
il francese ha preso la traversa ok
attenzione la tolgo basta passa massa
basta una canzone basta al momento la
monna lisa the picture of the monna lisa
e ai ha mappato tirate serata che sta
giocando sia fisica d'attenzione la
vampa va tolto le pose le funzioni ti va
nemmeno mickey posto sai come non si
toglierà attenzione palla ma dopo
ragazzi è il casinò togliete da ballo
eccolo anche ai ha mancato le facce
e la storia si ripete 2006 proprio st
negoziato da quando ha segnato fabio
grosso mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
mamma mia come si gioca
tieni al pala lista è bravissimo aia
scarpaci fallo ed è rosso questo è
partita nel rosso attenzione che tengono
palla qua non la tengo
la terza dopo la iii bomer chapati store
voler aspetta contro leo fatto una merda
una cache ok ragazzi occhio che
ripartono la tolgo mammamia i francesi i
francesi la tiene benissimo a fare via
spector mamma mia hanno lottato allora è
stato le fans e kakà soft le forze che
anche a soft che l'estero la partita ma
per piacere
guardala chiti nella pal e mezzo
incredibile era piccolo in due ad essi
progetti stefano madonna vista l'ho
strozzata bravissimo ragazzi occhio di
partenza la toccata dello ster il
trovate fa vincere ma da chiara cosa
stavate facendo gilardino e del piero
che al di là poteva che dice la
bandierina c'è campo contro uno con di
francesi no mi dissocio mi dissocio non
devo andare così
data così anzi facciamo sta roba ok
eccoci 6 pronti
grasso attenzione attenzione che buona
attenzione che buona
mamma mia la gara ai cavalli imperia mo
si sta succedendo se devo sapere mai
domi 90 minuto il coccodrillo che non
toglie mette fuori cannavaro ancora
insiste paloschi il cannavaro cannavaro
contro play per totti che dopo avere per
gilardino
chi sa di non poter neanche vicino alla
bandierina ceca questo numero 31 dentro
del piero del piero non c'è del piero
qua mannaggia davvero bravissimo da
destra del piero alex stefy il magnifico
chiudete le valigie
andiamo a berlino andiamo a berlino ea
prenderci la grotta andiamo a bellino
per l'idv uno spettacolo ancora su
dimensioni di pirla non era trasmetto
che diventò comprate una voce nuova a
questo ragazzo piace mamma mia ragazza
come com'è bello vincere contro i
francesi ma com'è bello ma com'è bello
mandarle francese a casa come bello
bellissimo c'è ragazzi questa è la cosa
più io penso che non ci sia
soddisfazioni su siti sbagliato gioco
attenzione però che voleva riferire qua
con l'ultimo gol e allora lo facciamo il
retro non lo facciamo invece però si
sono difesi bene in due attenzione molto
forti da e mezzo se qualcuno me tirare
ragazzi nessuno ci credo la toccata ma
tocca ragazzi bravissimi siete veramente
stati un bijoux ma grazie agire o bravo
stefano nichi l'italia campione o parsa
mary francese
mi dispiace per un lavabo seppur la
tanto frates e le tanto po mi dispiace
però che è che ce la fa a zuma donna
così di donna così bene che sono clipper
a martina che i francesi in video sempre
favi usa
la storia si ripete è vero da giulia
grazie automation lei mister tom rng
champ ei neri sta bene vista d'occhio
tutti calcolati maravilla c è lo stiamo
cercando anche noi sai mai non ho fatto
giocare non è cosa che cazzo con cardozo
mai convinto e giacomo ciao questo
rispetto dell'intelligenza artificiale
ma che cazzo te lo diceva lui lei avesse
effettivamente potrebbe avere un senso
va bene o comunque la di mese prima
l'hai capito ma i server di si uccise
sono online adesso è ma sono le 9 19 e
non ha senso fare software ag a perché
si occupo del tempo che loghi e
particola barche siamo facciamo partire
la vela non ha veramente senso al minimo
due ore di avere perso il minimo però
ragazzi lo giocheremo questi giorni da
idee lo giochiamo una gara di natura già
pronta e tu stesso quando vuoi farlo di
melo lo rifacciamo la riorganizziamo
prossima settimana ma nazzaro e ci sarà
un'altra pagina chi va bè quello sicuri
sperando che non lo fa non ho fatto
altro che lo faceva sì ma adesso vi
vogliamo la giocò ci sono i siti dove
che volete costantemente ma non ci credo
un saluto al mio simon preferite che è
tutto perché grazie si muovo di essere
passato ma sempre my brother nei bronchi
ma questa è rimasto bene non è vero
scherzavo il coccodrillo e niente palo
io non potevo fare nulla se non essere
sotto un cielo sbagliato
no bellissimo generano balza del proprio
camion e poi mai ha poca memoria guaio
ho detto che c'è gente che mike ness è
nei box storiche il turbo magari è bene
che quasi guccione cos'è
be nice ragazzi bene scherza
noi stiamo perso be nice l storico
farcene che box garage a stefano ragazzo
magnifico cia.it report sport display
week and trade name quello giocare solo
inglese
brava perché non ce l'avevo thaicom
insegnante di inglese molto però ci
siamo che io le risposi comunque i
occupiamo da tempo almeno una roba
veramente
ecco marinaio
vabbè dai adesso ragazzi di ritorno al
serio e scusatemi so che state fronte a
chi è debole stacking tech i somari ci
tocca pure donation cioè a peter de
france e tanto meno forse fu un
magnifico cus bari scorrono come se
nemmeno il suo high di coccodrillo ce
n'è solo uno stato magnifico su itunes e
bo and it's gone bad boys dorme e cioè
il turgore boxe kick off
ecco fazioso e cioè tu cartacea bowie
sgorga conflitto di fronte il bayern e
bayer buona buona mescola daimon player
promesso bari che bossi gli spot in
default for jazz and che è sempre
magnifico ed è all those are going for
growth and nice côte nota gay man is no
go rai.tv skies ingolfando il regime dei
venti miss line dove ce ne stai davvero
devo nemmeno morning nei monitor a
youtube e lode ma senza farvi jazz go
race clarin this way porters enjoyed
shot by the shoot memphis smarrisci and
rare gioia ancora raggiunte schifo bud
collins e forlì avversari piccoli alberi
scarsi paris abbondante partita
la partita insomma è il maestro
benvenuto in giacomo ema bentornato ma è
emanuele è mai scusato mi sono perso il
nostro ma perché una volta gli aironi
scappato il nome o il dossier
sai se sei quindi dall'iridato carbonero
se ne il sensei ci sta e manuele master
back il sensei parlare inglese facebook
metodo per chi sa mark martin fornendo
nation perché mi lingua di nuovo nelle
impostazioni inserimenti in cui
inserimento di lingua normale magari sir
insomma no di nuovo contro non si quanto
martino 9 gara che quello lì non
pronunciabile forte forte bendata non è
niente di noi cioè mi riprende
sufficiente un insulto caso credo che
sia interpretabile come lo so se non è
male però non so come poterla prendere
d'acqua stoccata così l'ho pensata sul
muro è cominciata in mezzo non so come
se no mi avvampa tagli dai raga però
adesso leggo questo discorso col suo
discorso niente trovo brava come vedere
grazie combinata e tutto il tempo che va
così lui avo madonna
va beh
arrivano le maniche grazie ragazzi dai
doni il problema è sto qua però ricorda
spesso descritto nel saper disco dl di
ragazzi la combinata dischord in
description dovete girare e
chiacchierare tra di voi e interagire
tra di voi king description mai cari
ragazzi
trovate il link o mamma mia che toccò
numero stiamo materia i due scatenati la
nonna è bella grazie mille senso nation
ok aperto fidiamo bellissimo
no dai ragazzi questo cosa fatti erano
tira papa no io veramente non so più che
fare dunque sta giocando aveva quello è
il mix di quel tipo meani sta giocando
solo quello ragazzi cioè riscoprendo
dimmi che gol
si si no l'avrei voluto dire tantissimo
però sai era la cosa che più desiderava
al mondo di dirti in questo momento ma
va bene cosi
[Musica]
mamma mia
ci siamo dati un bacetto in aria ha
voglia di più o i knicks news è arrivato
il primo vero stipendi della mia vita da
contrattualizzato indeterminatamente
leggi e tanti auguri emanuele in bocca
al lupo
dedichiamo questo gol mai siamo molto
contenti per te caro ti abbracciamo
grazie mille ds passato anche ovviamente
ovviamente file ma ovviamente fa il
maestro perché è bello ma essere sensei
ma di vita ti si verifica lui e
scansione zen favolosi mamma mia ragazzi
ma cosa sto vedendo così che forse
soltanto di codere domani per questo
tipo ma pure a nesta ma da noi non
succede mai quando non entra per poi poi
entra così però vabbè ora che cosa non è
l'ente che scandalo non era entrata lì
sempre lui è quella giocata solo bravo
ancora con giulia vera gara ho fatto
altro ieri casa va bene tutto e niente
però sono scandaloso perché lo bam pato
perchè lo sto togliendo delle scatole
questo qua che mi lascia tirare io non
tiro ragazzi visto che io sono il più
scarso lui è più forte che ne dite se
passo la mia partita ad ifa cerca di
distruggerlo dei mottetti scriverai
segnerà i suoi molto probabile maracaibo
la parola la brava mamma papà palo forza
9 tirare sì ma dove
sotto al 7 arriva la di cielo il primo e
l'altro da un problema sono io non è
vero il problema e che gol
no perché c'è la vivacità di usami pro
ragazzi non ho assolutamente turco
prepara questa quale ma ci vado lo
stesso tanto e ragazzi in che non c'è
quel tipo ma dovremmo buttare la palla
in avanti così eccoli la pasta mamma mia
mamma mia
ma cosa stanno facendo
ma se è bello non ci arrivo ci sono io
la miseria ragazzi sempre lì come la
come l'ha buttata ci ha creduto fino
alla fine lui ci ha creduto fino alla
fine
mamma mia che l'avevo tolta ragazzi e
l'avevo veramente tolta avevo veramente
tolta vorrei tanto vedere il randista
persone bello e te lo direi io sapessi
le bacche mondo però non so io comunque
lui altissima gli altri sono più bassi
perché comunque alla fine fa fa una
media oppure intervento legge anche non
solo assieme finirà anche abbastanza
bilanciati questo quasi come c'è in 22
minimo no perché parlo e non mi
concentro ti prego no lì c'è sempre
cattedra aveva sbagliato io scusatemi
era davvero pareggiarla io sì vabbè ma
che sfiga e allora credibile no i soci
abbiamo 40 secondi
30 ancora essere un gol
dai bello è tanto se lorito abbia fatto
ma almeno giocata 15 secondi in avanti
by the day spingere spingiamo visto
[Musica]
rimbombato un po
angelo bravo non la toccherò mai però ci
provo bravo però no se la tocca viola
prendevo peccatissimo perché così si va
subito per non far vedere il drunk
significa per quello
ebbene mi sa che ha fatto anche prima
allora abbiamo visto bene platino attiva
certo che è platino anche più basso dei
tre ma perché se tu lefty prima non lo
vuole fortuna perché si vuole portare no
no qualcosa allora che gli fa vincendo
anche non c'è percezione che vedere la
vj tv globo
grazie mille nation e fu così che fa
viene 2032 a vetri e magari magari caro
magari caro quello arrivato stefano nino
no ma io non faccio più iscritti cosa
davvero bene che youtube nel 2020 visto
brutalmente il numero di iscritti
infatti i miei contro te ti avrebbero
ragioni di magliano stroncati youtube
contro incontro teso mi dissocio da
sciami di social di social e sociali
socio dicendo cose davvero andate a
vederli le d'attis per i tifosi tutti i
canali hanno iniziato avere molti meno
iscrizioni rispetto al 2009 nemici
autori li finanziano più iscritti
papà papà beh io in realtà questa
sincera cioè rispetto agli anni scorsi
no rispetto ai primi anni si ma rispetto
con discorsi scorsi no cerchi me non
sono sempre quanto 40k 50 60 km rimarrà
costante però consiglia che ti prima e
contro terra c'erano mesi da 159
certo adesso fanno 30 40mila come tutti
no scusate non troppo vicino perché
pensavo gli iscritti
sto pensando soltanto agli iscritti e
non la posso toccare il capoccione
casinò che legge per ogni cosa mi disse
navi di socio a prescindere quando parla
stai fluidi socia prescindere che dice
cose grazie a perchè dici cose e ho
paura a daniel bahr perfetto rimbalzo
ottimo tra l'altro incredibile
niente già mangiati tre gol da come
amministrato stavano stata messa ed
accordi ma finalmente giochiamo con
esseri umani non con quel matto perfetto
guerra che anche un cross perfetto ed
eccolo non ci credo tutto giusto tutto
giusto guarda come quassù per favi e poi
cross ma io non mi devo veramente fare
un mettermi in focus perché non so non
so ma so pure preso la traversa e poi
entrato di certo numero di anzi a noi
non sarebbe mai mai mai mai mai mai
successo ma perché gli è rimbalzata in
mezzo precisa perché perché
il papa non era e non la faccio non
sparano la parano la bara la sparata noi
sono riuscito a non essere risucchiato
mi dissocio
grazie maestro cosa vuol dire abbraccio
civediamo in centro nel tuo corpo del
ragazzo è bene e cosa intenda così
impari privati il ministro quindi faccio
vista
no no no no no no no no no no se tutto
giusto e tutto giusto guarda io ragazzi
che attraverso la passati due minuti di
partita ho fatto 10 punti non so mi
dissocio da effetti di prova lana
traversa guarda canali che comunque li
stava aggirando la palla non so se da
quando ai 6 milioni di iscritti una
legge non gli oni disinstallare internet
explorer per forte sono vecchi menezes
temi del cassettino che gli ho fatto non
esiste neanche come concrete che sperano
che ci pensa sistema a rete microsoft ed
è già era anche di col web press
magari lo guardavi l'abilità piccolo ma
parli con me tutte e due regali come
disponga no ma stai scherzando io
tantissimi ricordi ager guardare con il
sacco vedo venire questo sta gente qua
però questo non lo ricordo ed io odiavo
giuntina and his name i liberali me può
saperlo
infatti a sentirla non è vero che è
andata lì dove ero io
aia nota quella che hanno prima relativa
sta facendo ben 22 punti di cui avete
povera scusate guardalo
ce lo siamo look al kings grazie caro da
donation 2014 dico che si è cambiato ma
che ci sia per cambiarmi la giornata
sono incontrati da vivo grazie per tutto
grazie al perfetto e che proverà
bellissimo mi hanno esploso grazie caro
speriamo speriamo guarda come vola la
palla e o rivederci di beccare tutti
specie presto espresso storici spesso
bravo di gray tolto normale signori lui
piace fa ma mi sa che quella lapide john
cena allora che lo zio john cena cioè
proprio io guardo year odiavi non lo so
la faccia proprio con tanti giovani io
guardavo soltanto si incontri spiando
perdesse e alla madonna fiori non è in
terra era letterino letterine di un sit
in italia se a me piace tantissimo
battista poi finita fa avengers no ma
quasi
quello che lascia tutte le capriole che
la maschera che facciamo capriole è ok
bene visti mysteria previsti eddie
guerrero top cosa ci stava e morto
quello ricordo io mi dissocio perché
parla mister ho capito non c'è niente di
male però un po paura mista cielo aperto
ok paranoico ma no scusami stesso bene
sapere ai turbo e che dovrebbe essere
pericoloso per mandare il live con pavia
invece il contrario ma perché deve
essere ricostruita io sono totalmente
clima a livello di casa di immagine dei
canali capito o no sì sì perché una
volta le dicevo il mattino ma perché io
sono io non parlo mai di niente di
niente di come niente ma se devi dal
fatto della zona ma io non voglio bravi
bravi bravi fa vigenti l'hula hoop
teatro 9 euro se mi saluti ma però denti
salutavo comunque tavolo già salutato
prima pro grazie grazie al supporto e
luca i kings colpa dei caratteri ho
dovuto abbreviare cosa mi metto solo
t.ribeiro abbreviato comunque si capisce
non tua
questo è proprio 4 a 4 perché non c'era
nessuno grazie di stef evidentemente
l'impronunciabile ho comprato da
borracce io lo comprate anche voli di
stato che mi sono dissociato ha messo la
prescindendo da noi siamo qua e allora
niente la pena va bene praga in 44
arriva adesso eccolo 32 e lasciate
cadere lasciati cadente non l'ha
lasciata cadere non deve toccare sì sì
adesso riparte nel segno l'apertura di
toccata guarda guarda la guarda
aiutatemi aiutatemi mi sarei studio mi
sarei stupito e non mi sarei stupito che
un successo sofferto ma bisogna
rischiare sempre lì è giusto che
obiettivi grazie luca king report serri
for drawing perché ha buttato il match
subito non ci sta scherzando non conosco
il significato no e quindi mi dissocio
da allora di che cosa certa per scindere
sempre difficile ragazzi mi dissocio da
qualsiasi cosa che non sa tipo come era
l'altra volta gli amminoacidi la
conception gli aminoacidi senso che non
so cosa vogliano dire che i social
fascino giustissimo giustizia so niente
e che rechi si chiama marcate il socio
verificate in tribunale che uno si
difende dalla crudezza i nostri mario
visto un dissociato ma se non sbaglio
torino uno scherzo mi disse ma si sa che
è bellissimo basta dire nomi di persone
vicine
sarà finita prima difesa maestro spera
che ha fatto il profilo bella che a
questo qui lui cantare che son quelli
futuri infine del tipo il secondo bando
il pip no calcio sarà accorto ragazzo
ben zero punti quindi il casco lasciate
a me fate voi fate come volete
a me va importano ok papa no ragazza va
bene va bene
e invece no ragazzi orribile stato che
avevano invitato allora cosa facciamo
grossa e tutti i soci
se sommiamo i nostri punti facciamo 14
che il punteggio minimo degli altri 4
rel
rana senza che andò bene questa è questo
qua è veramente competitivi si tende
pall
in più per idevice doppio misto un
grosso incredibile per loro
7 siete in dodici scusa franco ci
credevo facevano anche no goal
la prima parata mamma mia mamma mia sono
stato punti tutti
niente mi posso dire capito che sono blu
per a chi voleva esplodere quello a
niente riuscito a fare il giro abbiamo
secondo ti piace tanto abbiamo tanto di
cui parlare allora è frate quando vuoi
ce ne sarebbe da discutere di quello mi
ha rischiato di segnare così così questo
ho saltato però non turbare minimalismo
praga ed è gol
mammamia step come cacchio di rimessa te
lo giuro grossi non ho visto niente
vediamo io sto facendo 66 punti uno
scritto vediamo bello supera la cucina
mi hanno prima al mese bella bellissima
ma dalla mia visione l'ancora tenete
tutto sto fatto in the mezzo non potete
tenerlo
lui era già lì sapeva già che ci siamo
manca lo sharingan lo zio ma torino
siamo chiamati non ci siamo capiti deve
essere anche chiamato proprio mentre mi
ammazzi mi dissocio
ok mi di struzzo li strozzo
questo qui doveva ecco vettoriato stessa
in compenso cercato di parare lui va il
meeting dei abbiamo tenuti per
pareggiare no scusate abbiamo adesso per
segnare due mete due mesi per vinci
touch the ball
negate bello vinto tutti no ragazzi c
non ci posso credere come anche questa
palla guarda che sono scambiate tirate
pirani chi ritira kiss
porca vacca
ok no niente ragazzi pessimo e tutto ciò
non è che il tunnel che è imbarazzante
bello sto misto posso fare questo tipo
30 secondi by step bara è bravissimo
bravo brutto tocco che ha fatto lui e si
sbaglia tanto l'ha fatto il brutto tocco
è imbattuto nel congo grillo che l'ha
punito
bene le vigenti per respinta argenti
bullock grazie della location siro non
lo sto leggendo perché mi sto
concentrando il suo recupero
caro cannes grazie mille intanto adesso
leggo che mi concentro sei ragazzi
giustamente migliore ma che no no
ragazzi non la posso togliere sì che poi
si che l'ha tolta anche senza turbo
ragazzo che ha paura si mamma mi avrà
veramente tolto il bloccato la porta
bello non ho più la dignità tirati rate
tirate kever gol della gente voleva
glielo devo levare lui al centro bravo
secondo me in due siamo dei pazzi o no
non l'ho demolito adesso la vampa spero
che crossa ha fatto abbiamo la libertà
come non entrata st palla ragazzi e li è
brutta brutta non ho assolutamente modo
di prenderla siamo posizionati veramente
da schifo male i ragazzi vediamoci per
favore ritirate
ok davo vai vai di amici posto
mamma mia
non riesco è bloccata li bravo ma quello
la presa a sta però niente la sollecita
bam parlo pazzesco regate come lo
spirito o la laurea e kick off di sei
minuti preferito quindi no non c'è
nessun ma grazie all'incentivo del globe
grazie caro o cara grazie mille ok
supergentile che questo vada un po mi
fai come vuoi da bravo è bravo lui
pessimo pessimo ok arriva un altro
termine caro golberg alberico bravi
ragazzi bravi tutti bravi adesso è ora
di posarsi no assolutamente no bravo di
chi nikiniki di pichici qualcuno c'è
qualcuno c'è qualcuno lo stesso sta
suonando il turbo da un'ora ok no mamma
mia mamma mia mamma mia mamma mi aveva
girato non tocchino ma ci credi io non
so perchè visto questo in mezzo ragazzi
e mezzo precisa per loro è la cosa
incredibile
ok foschi quando uscirà lo speciale caro
allora che via via via via via via il
tiro della terra è una cagata di
settimana prossima esce il semi speciale
che un contentino insomma perché no il
vero è quello vero stiamo ancora
lavorando ci siamo per ora purtroppo mi
sa che a questo punto no
da che brutto signori o lisciato binari
tutti abbiamo nessuno l'ha presa
no perché io sono andato in cielo detto
fisica se lo zio la fisi of this a
vedere com'era anch'io uguale in
compenso stiamo buttando fuori l'acqua
dalla barca da esatto si fa via
dall'acqua brosco e stavo dicendo uscirà
tra un mese
no tra una settimana esce semi speciale
l'altro invece esce
quello vero appena riusciamo purtroppo
non ha una data comunque mesi purtroppo
quando lo vedrete capirete il permesso
[Musica]
qualcuno mi sa dire come si chiamano le
ruote di fabi ruote prot
qui a queste quarchioni credo che sia
una roba di halloween anche cerchioni e
pneumatici con quale turbato lo sto
dicendo non so che cosa ha fatto meno
schifo di me sicuro bella questa cosa in
mezzo precisa per loro è bravo fa vj
bravo chi può giocare a questi livelli
con questo killer croc belli amos va
bene proprio stecca da biliardo lì all
ex grazie caro del supporto a pagamento
e uno spoilerato nessuna casa il giorno
prima
no non si è vista socio viene sarà già
uscito lino sei messo due anni ho capito
ma io c'ho dell'ex degli schemi da
rispettare abito ma senza una casa più
grande di una gru
non penso di aver capito no siamo nel
caso di casa di minecraft a scamparla di
maggio ragazzi o ragazze ho fatto il
cross non era granché per l'azione mie
sono scattati due senza turbine in modo
pazzesco si madonna doppio tono forze
ok mezzo erano tutte va bene ma vincente
lo rimpallo ai tratti frenze grazie di
aspettare con tutti il ragazzo speciale
bravo là dietro
grazie pigra cester giri tanto dai nei
video di parigi al minuto 9 40 sembra
che ci siano stoccato parla ma perché un
video pre registrato lui per registra
ragazzi ma quale vive pubbliche
nella mia casa se sei passata a casa mia
normale in realtà tanto sto facendo 0.24
punti presente 0 non so quando lo ho
smesso
comunque no stavo dicendo dicendo che è
praticamente sennò c'è il video pre
registrato di camera di casa mia non è
neanche così tanto e forse il video un
meno preregistrato di tutti loro e kato
quadrilogia giorni fa lei è recato nelle
tre giorni fa nostri giorni fa perché
era venerdì si prima che facesse una
gara non è neanche così tanto
preregistrato bene alla fine tutti gli
altri un po di più la parano ma non ho
capito che cosa stanno facendo
onestamente dopo si sono messi in porta
in tre fermi sfiga ma che cacchio dc ma
che sembra a bombolo male sembra pinball
ferro rimbalza tutte le giocavi a al
pinball colori windows pensa mamma
mirabelle come fatto mio gioco
e invece non ho mai capito legale di
campo ferito
allora per titolo coperte o scoperte
quando ho iniziato ad andare in quinta
liceo praticamente era nell'esame
praticamente
c'è qualcosa ti mette tipo 2 o 3 vuol
dire che ci sono 3 min e vicino al tuo
spazio cioè quindi c'è un 3 vicino vuol
dire che hai tremine vicino al cosa che
hai cliccato se c'è un muro dire che nei
una sola quindi a probabilità di per
carlo è molto inferiore
che vedrebbe comprare chiaro 5 adesso
vuoi mascherarlo cinque anni diceva
spesso perché questa informatica ragazzi
informatica ha spiegato marino sta cosa
praticamente quando eravamo in classe mi
ha spiegato lui è la tolgo reagan
anatolico mamma bravo l'ad nostro angelo
custodia vangelo appunto perché l'hai
detto l'angelo piace a voi ma poi
l'angelo custodia cioè che cosa c'è
apcom e passata in mezzo a tutti e 2 st
palla scusatemi se pilot chiedo niente
niente ho letto cose in chat che sia una
scelta davvero guard quindi sono generò
allora ben più diversi cosa niente
niente niente tu non sai nulla ma la mia
chat mancata una cosa ragazzi non ho
messo perché non superò i quadri col
trap insomma stiamo rischiando lasciando
ben 154 punti ragazzi ma di che parliamo
abbiamo fischiando e fischia la mi
sembra che non voleva per forza il 2 e
se lo bramiamo guardano a 321 dati ma
quanta poca fiducia ciai e fai solo bene
facciamo schifo
non so come contro questo così non è
tanto non è tanto il fatto che noi
facciamo schifo che quello è che faccio
che stimano che il discorso è che
ok che dice scriptato no ma mi contro la
mamma mia che tiro dello scalo
conseguente orecchio distrutto lo step
trincerino con un bel 3 auguri dei g8
per atene all'ato al o comunque palo
nel dubbio paloma tube giovanni ciao
caro e grazie per la donation supporto
ragazzi vogliamo ricordarvi che dovrete
sopportarci c'è la super chat con i
super stipendi chiaramente coperto e
tutto super super super sticker super
favi superday e c'è anche adesso super
abbonati non con la sola bonati dove ci
sono vari prezzi da scegliere anche sul
canale stefania credo se si fosse forse
via belli calma dal dg matrice gli
ambulanti sia venuto il dubbio
ok giovanni di pangrazio abbonamento
massimo per il nostro giovanni grazie
caro allora la propria ma perché mi
interessa prendere quel verso la fine
come sempre bravi i ragazzi a fatto ben
0 calista partita mi sento 3.9
beh che ne facciamo uno al contrario
neanche mi fa entrare allora gioca tu io
non è la nostra forza è anche
l'abbonamento super mi dissocio dice
giulia designer altro argomento in salvo
[Musica]
e io raga sono talmente fendi che ho
paura parlate e uscite ragionamento
inserti se lo sappiamo sappiamo però se
volete che apriamo si artisti ci
salutiamo nel menu regalo che parte una
partita parità e poi veramente andare ad
almeno 22 ore è già su un poker sono
proprio bisogna vedere già non vanno
bene almeno due e mezzo però se volevo
tirarla forzare come si dice non si dice
si dice sono in counter strike source
due ore a forzare incanta sai che è un
termine che si utilizza quando non ha i
soldi per comprare l'arma per vincere al
round allora con prima di tutto quello
che hai per forza per comprare ma
contento i ragazzi di quante ne facevo
cagare ma di gaming e l'incredibile
facevano interrogazione di storia
raccontati spiega mostrerò presidente
prof incanta strike se tu prendi le
metto della cavea counter strike
tantissimo avrò 300 ligio la meriva
costalli armeli per gioco perché
l'atleta più stupida la metà corsa le
avances
ormai se diciamo che per quello va bene
anche con è sin arnaldi sindaco di sori
a di stato coordinati stato realizzato
cosa vuol dire che meno competitivo
secondo me devono apparire un parere
ok è diviso non è vero
mamma tv shows mio padre lavorava
beh va beh certo la diga che gol e
vadillo cosa tolto quel altro la tolgo
io ho insistito ma non so quanto serve
invece forse non serve un appello verso
tocca all'indietro cumulo eh vabbè ma
dai mali povera abbiamo capito madama
gara merito è però trova o capiva guarda
leggermente più lento ma guarda che
tocca fatto per una sera
mamma mia hai un sapere enciclopedico
studiava avete capito cosa vuol dire se
non avete neanche capito dai buona auto
io ho mai capito ma non me lo ricordo
quella roba ditelo forzare allora quando
tu compri bensì in settimana e non ha i
soldi dobbiamo spiegarlo e quando tu mi
stai giocando in competitivo su counter
strike e ai pochi soldi quindi tu come
la vedi comprare armi giuste che costano
più soldi e l'armatura eccetera e non
hai abbastanza solidi giochi con la
pistolina siccome che se giochi con la
pistola nella lounge lo perdi quasi
sicuro perché fai schifo allora forzi
significa che prendi la l'arma più
schifosa che c'è senza prendere la
naturale niente giusto per non rimanere
con la pistonina però è una scommessa
perché se poi per dirla un ti trovi
questo vuol dire forzati adesso mi sono
ricordato finanziari grazie ragazzi
grazie a tutti grazie per la lezione di
lcd è che questi melo che deve andare a
posto ma sono recitate ha visto
impegnato con questa facendo e da un'ora
che non fa più giocando 40 mentale 19 ho
smesso
ho detto io nessuno due punti
capitolo 19 io questo meno è stato
arrestato un braccio niente e ho perso
turbo finita proprio youtube ma non
leggi lasciato non è vero non la leggo
ragazzine solo che a hilla 100 ma solo
che a parigi da parte di parigi è vero
dall'est in chat starò bovino in parte
che non è vero noi scritto però è che
già da rocha e palata che culo giorno da
rocchi ed edifici e ragazzi leggere
sempre lasciato perché 67 come perdi il
momento prendi gol la puoi leggere
quando c'è un gol c'è una pausa è questa
la versione gentile la versione cattiva
dico io se no facciamo paragoni di ieri
tender rispondo dicendo se non vi leggo
perché vivente scritte cose foto
interessanti
vabbè questo questo è forse non è non mi
dissocio tra tutti ma perché non mi
riesce più un dribbling dall'anno scorso
signori incredibile lasciano bello da
ragazzi siamo 2 a 0 ma anche almeno 50
contro questi non so come sia possibile
ora ho capito lo scandalo ma io me ne
vado geografica quando vincevamo
trasmisero che gli over ho sempre in
mente questa scena dio che striscia da
roche taseer questa logica da roche
vediamo cosa ci facesse conti se c'è già
nikic e prendere kramsky in mano è stato
tanto fra i l'acqua come è possibile
come era possibile questa scena e non
l'avete li toccate là dentro
adesso nero laga guarda che è servita
per noste come non lo so no
madonna era col fatto quello che penso
che estratto sognerò due cose gli alert
magari mamma mia ragazzi grazie a tutti
abbiamo praticamente traverse anche ciò
che ho fatto a non inviare a non fare un
cronista partita non so io magari non
guardo il tabellone che dici palla alta
ma che cosa sto facendo macché controllo
volevo fare quindi controlla ma non
volevo fare niente di tutto ciò ma basta
da riusciamo trend estivo ma volevo fare
i miei il primo controllo nel secondo e
ladino volo fare niente di tutto questo
proprio dallo spacco il controller solo
perché non si trovano più oggetti
elettronici in jeans cosa
[Applauso]
scatta il silenzio assenso sognati
l'altro giorno con tutto e credo nazioni
sia altro giornale radio stato
devastante giulia effettivamente no però
il fatto che stiamo giocando ormai la
tipo 4 ore quasi 24 ore no no io non ho
usato le alle 16 alla fine perché è
stato mezz'ora dopo pensare il sir che
ci passa come minimo quattro ore al
giorno penso io vorrei chiedere
all'amministrazione di più ma vedo anche
di più vi risponderà vogliono vorrei
chiedere ma visto come gioco capisco
perché non mi rispondi ci sta come
dargli torto quel povero ragazzo ed è
vedersi stai partite quale faccio lo
togli ragazzi e vabbè allora gli hanno
tappato io che lasciando questo me ne
sbatte un cazzo state che prendono
affatto munim war non ho paura che non
riesco sempre per un millesimo di
secondo non spiegabile scusami scusa
mente niente
cosa importa da abbia fatto girare la
out tecnico il magnifico niente
ma parappa state dato kate walsh fallito
no sono scandalo o i piedi a banana ma
era un bellissimo trovai di bravi fatto
da quella roba lì stef bravissimo
problema che avevo diciotto di turbo ma
io veramente
ma allora una volta che non faccio il
coccodrillo lisciando attenzione le dive
bravissimo pensava fa troppo lenta
perché era da fermo per giocare meglio
metti contro sotto la scrivania ma la
tecnica è quella con i piedi perché poi
già calato del gioco torrisi le ruote a
banana
esatto ma tengo la ai ragazzi hai visto
che non è né importane ok tranquillo
girato nemmeno l'epic agli altri bravo
perché l'affare rimasta non arriva a
veronica gli altri
[Risate]
quello era un mio fan che si vendicava
non ci credo non ci credo
la palla in mezzo per gli avversari a
poco fa così essenziale no mi ha rapito
il turno del momento
e va beh vinci lo rimpallo te l'ho
tirato addosso soldi però non tutto va
bene purché non è male se rimbalza
giusta stefy mezzo di prova bravissimo
nichi tu vai vai bene signori o
frammenti st partito sta facendo 50
punti
pare che non sto più giocando la non
spiega mi sono girato ma ci sta però
tanto voglio dire dopo quattro anni che
ci giochiamo ci può anche stare ma voi
siete sempre sul pezzo invece dopo un po
dopo un po operaio sta correndo dritto
in realtà che mi sto lasciando
completamente caricare da voi dente
cariato tirano e senza ma perché non
lascia toccare il disagio e il vice
invece invece invece invece invece 142
buonissimo buonissimo se per caso tocca
a qualcuno non l'ha toccata nessuno qui
a tocco ancora in mezzo la palla non
vuole smuoversi aqua ok la j
scusa era un fatto sta che non volevano
ti vedremo scusami tira tira pizza come
pc ok imparavi mamma mia che ti ho
aspettato se aspettate era proprio lì no
no ragazzi non sono accorto o filo turbo
non so come voterò no turbo turbo turbo
no
mamma mia mamma mia che elastico quella
era quello che poi pampano e vabbè fatto
un elastico che c'era lio che ha visto
che ha donato
la super chat dove vado a demolire
questo qua mi ha saltato hanno fatto
bene non l'ho anche pappato la di adesso
ma segnare perché non lodevoli devo
vedere no ok dove uscito a toglierla in
qualche modo questo non è male senza mai
provato competitiva palombella ha
provato a togliere lui ti togli quindi
pronto rimane la la mandano via
ancora più a lato bello cura e rispetto
e lui ha già tutto no rega scusatemi ma
guarda chat stavo perché poi scusatemi e
non è neanche colpa mia perché è questo
qua è sempre dove io tiro la palla stava
guardando certe voletto buonasera
buonasera con il tono di gerry scotti
come hanno fatto ridere sono ingenti
let's go baby no no no no no no no no
non mi piace no no sono scandaloso
ragazzi perdona niente tempi
supplementari
no sono ancora andaluso dai ragazzi ma
dove ma dove signò ma dai ma dai ma non
è pensabile screen o ma ragazzi scusate
mi era già scritto ma per favore ma per
favore ma dov'è finita ma prima dai no
veramente ragazzi giuro supplementari mi
dissocio dalla e li perdiamo pure no
sicuro guardate i miei che li giochiamo
attenzione da 42 ministro nomina na na
na li giochiamo noi abbiamo girate
tirate tira tiro io con la mia di mezzo
di peso di mezzo di cacchio adesso
niente
ok ma vediamo di polizia al centro non
puoi perché le partite
volevo dirtelo ma non so come dirtelo
non è partito sarebbe stato una comoda
per dirtelo di si parlerà male e tira
adesso so ma nun c'ha se tiravi subito e
invece la buona anche così cavolo ti ha
proseguito secondo me non sorprende v
che non si aspettava anche lui sorpreso
anche io
esatto perché la brocca dire però non
c'è turbo non posso di partire signori
poteva non esserci equa teste non l'ho
preso
ma l'attaccate volta che avete turbo
insomma io ti sto aspettando di questo è
un bellissimo tiro
mamma mia occhio che vado sul rimbalzo
io ok via prova a tentare di tirare cioè
mette di mezzo questo fa maggio
istruttore non fatti scaricare e non
vado ok o chissà con che cattiveria
rimbalzo complicato per l'art
ragazza erano era per poi in realtà vi
giuro che non mi sentivo non me la
sentivo praga bravo bello
no non lo devo vito bono madonna tirato
il freno a mano li per tevere per
rimanere fermo anche un certo punto di
gol brutti ma utili per lottomatica tra
victoria e della bandiera anche per la
prima abbiamo visto partita 111
regalarci giray ammette ora poi papa
farà solo l'ultima dai tagli della swan
per i ragazzi raga l'ultima proprio oggi
bel gameplay li si utilizza comunque
bello l'hanno migliorata metto il
cappello il dettaglio dell'acqua hai
visto l'argomento che ti potevi
specchiare thank you for the nation
caro mamma mia mi sono spaventato
anch'io
grazie caro ma io non sono in grado
bello lo stato che una massa dove era lo
zio cercherà il controlla lì a lei si
guarda guarda gara lo voleva proprio
ma perché io quando ma perché io quando
le tolgono le tolgo in realtà ci avete
fatto caso che quando tolgo i palloni
alla porta è nata non gli sto togliendo
e soprattutto un fake cioè come
possibile è tutto scriptato
ok meglio quella palla come cavolo la
prende così la prendete lo stesso ma se
non la tocca vera gol su un altro camera
insieme a quel tipo di ma infatti c'era
l'auto camera gol è stato un fenomeno
non so come ci è arrivato ma cavolo non
so che cosa ha fatto e non del tono
bravo e non ero io ragazzi quando non
era un millisecondo dopo cacchio l'avrei
toccata una mano
ok
bella ciao vabbè vabbè pessimo bello si
stava mio cielo c'era un peccato però
stavo arrivando anche a supportarti
consistenti di quante volte è stato
schiacciando il turbo bene grazie ad un
action carol mm quante ore di gioco in
3d
vabbè quanto ai 3.000 3.803 libro 500
caro o cara veramente poca in confronto
a te sai almeno 100 ma voi questo è
buonissima figura figurano le migranti
di cartapesta
ci sono forse la vita è bella ragazza è
stato definitivamente la maledizione non
c'è nulla da fare ed ecco colloca la
sono riuscita tra voi
foxy grazie milano eccomi da giacomo
gara niente ragazzi di partite così
scandaloso perché non ha fatto il doppio
salto inchiostro gioco con lo faccio ste
cose mi vorrei strappare le braccia
busani step perdonami aveva chiaramente
sarà anche intendiamo serate no dai raga
due minuti e 32 cosi ci credo ma ti
schifo stava rendere prende turbo no no
io no perché lo so che era lei
bravissimo ma allora entrata per cosa no
ha vinte rimpallo non ci credo brano io
sono e allora non è che è toccata
diciamo solo che non sia un altro ha
provato a fare una roba li porto io se
volete va bene facciamo enrico mattei
gol
così i ragazzi per far ancora adesso
eccolo hai fatto bene a 9 avresti fatto
verrà stilata perché non avevo paura non
avevo paura
volevo dire avevo paura di tifare per
nessuno te la del attivo il v sync
fratello è già attivo veri e non è
quello che pensi lei sync il desing no
non mi siedo mi funziona
ok mamma mia di un panico ha detto 16
parole secondo solo occhio a cavallo
provandone mezzo vogliamo lo tocca io
non sono riuscito per l'attenzione alla
quarta ci ha lasciato
bravissimo mammamia secondo motore è
rifatto kg ok pure come fanno ad
aspettarsi anche questo è incredibile ex
un peccato potevo magari uscita una cosa
buona per stefano no voglio tirare ma
questi tira giorno bravo qualcuno c'è o
no ma era bravo ma non hanno più turbo e
mangiava bene anche pinci me lo stai
dicendo
ma l'uso come bravo vai tirato di latina
tira già adesso perché sono sentita
bravo perché lui già stravizio diritti
reattiva e tira come cazzo fai a tirare
brutti non puoi tirare questo gioco puoi
ragazzi oddio attengo la tengo ma perché
non l'ho toccata da ragazzi basta è
finita l'ultima persa
vabbè la sono giocata comunque guarda
che ci mette contro tutti di a 22
penso ormai tutte le pole kill anche
perché è come se non l'avete mai avessi
giocate io invece una reazione a maran
calato ragazzi a sono uscito quindi
assente più l'audio scusa ok ci siete
ragazzi io stacco vi ringrazio per aver
servito dai ragazzi
l'oro è fuori dal letto nessuno è
perfetto questo è grazie allora fu un
bacino a tutti ci vediamo alla prossima
live che è domenica
io invece vediamo quando ci decidiamo di
vedere ok ok va bene